Nobody knows. Oh right. We're live
John Ronson, Hawaii. It fell. Hey,
how are you guys for doing this
man? I appreciate, I'm glad I,
I couldn't tell you the number of people
who've said he should do to record the
number of people who set up.
I've got Joe Rogan soak it about
Bohemian Grove or just took it about
psychopaths.
You have to come on.
Well I'm friends with Alex Jones
and Alex Jones told me many, many,
many years ago,
uh,
that they are burning
effigies and Bohemian Grove.
They're worshiping Molik the owl God,
when I went to pay,
he didn't grow up with Alex tone.
That's a note.
That's like going to Disneyland with
Mickey Mouse. Yeah, it was kind of my,
it was kind of my idea. I sent him
to fill out the kind of sound like,
I mean this isn't strictly speaking to,
but I kind of sometimes feel a little bit
like Alex Jones is Simon cowel because
before,
cause this is like way back in the mid,
mid to late nineties when he was
like really famous in Austin,
but kind of not that well known outside.
I was working with this producer,
John Sargent. Basically we, we,
we notice something which was that
a lot of people on the fringes, um,
that Islamic fundamentalists and Neo Nazis
and militia people will have this one
thing in common, which is they
were all conspiracy theorists.
They all believed in, you know, the evil
power of Bilderberg and Bohemian Grove.
Um, so I thought it'd be good to
try and infiltrate those places. Um,
but I didn't want to infiltrate Bohemian
Grove alone because frankly I was
scared.
So we've met Alex Jones
when he was rebuilding David
Koresh's Church at Waco and
he seemed kind of Gung Ho. He was
rebuilding David Koresh's church. Yeah,
that was the first time I met Alex Jones.
I wouldn't know where Randy Weaver. Uh,
I, I became friends with the wave for
family, um, who are the weavers again now,
Ruby Ridge, you know, white separatists.
And so I've got really friendly
with Randy's daughter rate.
And then I went with Randy to,
to Waco and Alex said there was
this kind of crazy bad, the Waco,
and I was like, who the fuck is that?
What year was this? This was about nine,
probably [inaudible] 98 maybe. That's when
I met him. Yeah. Yeah, I met him in 98.
Ah, yeah, he was, yeah,
he was amazing. I mean,
I could tell it like I
drove to Austin with him.
Like he went to buy a new suit
cause he was like, you know,
giving a big talk at Waco and
like, yeah, everybody in the,
everybody in the clothing store was like
excited because Alex Jones had walked
in and started, he was like a big deal in,
in the neighborhood. But, but then, um,
but then I wanted somebody to sneak
into Bamyan Grove with and I asked David
Eick first I said, gee, could we go into
but he be girl? But he was like, no.
That's where they transform
themselves back as giant lizards.
Did he tell you that for
real? Yeah. He said, yeah.
He said that's where they
transform themselves back
and teach kind of abandoned
all that housing a yeah, he gets mad if
you bring it up. It does eight. Yeah.
Which you can't, you can't get mad
man. You hear that. You, you get, Oh,
you made a lot of speeches saying that
people transforming the lizards. Yeah.
You've got to own up to that shit.
Got To hope you said those exact words.
But this is going back a long time.
He said words.
He certainly strongly implied
that he believed that,
that it was at Bohemian Grove,
that they transform
yourself. I think you're in the
clear, because he gave many,
many interviews where he talked
about that that was a, a big,
well it was kind of in the early
days of the Internet would,
you can get away with saying stupid shit
like that and you didn't have a bunch
of people on reddit that immediately could
debunk your Twitter or Facebook where
they just knew something that
you did know. And I'm like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Transforming a lizard is get
the fuck out of here. Dude.
Has his big piece of evidence that the
Heman Grove was where the transform house
into lizards was because of this
woman called Kathy O'Brien who,
who said that she was a kidnap sex
slave. Uh, and actually it would be like,
let loose into the gardens of
the White House. Uh, George Bush,
Sr would like hunter.
And that was like his second game.
And so she wrote this book
about this called, um,
it was called something like
the crisis of democracy.
It was called the
transformation of America.
And she said it was at Bohemian Grove.
She was a kidnap sex
slave at Bohemian Grove.
And that's where it all happened.
And she was la and Bohemian Grove
was all based around this, um, this,
this river and the Russian
river. And, and so,
so that's where the Bohemian Grove
Room is first started with, with,
with Cathy O'Brien. That's
hilarious. Yeah. And, um,
so I thought like,
it can't be true that light George Bush
and Henry Kissinger or go to this club
out on the Saturday night,
they'll put on robes and have a mock
human sacrifice in front of a giant stone
owl. I thought that can't be true.
So I phoned up David Eick and I said,
which would occur trying to come with me?
And he's like, no. And then I thought,
well remember that crazy that you know,
that guy we met at Waco, Alex Jones,
maybe we should ask him.
So I called up Alex Jones and I said,
the fancy trying to get into piney grove.
And he was like, he was like, yeah,
I've got to get a cab. Well, we'll
get a hit of Cabo will get it.
I will get it routed our faces as
devil worshipers will confront them.
Gag about they're globalists
devil worshiping. Yeah.
Evil. So that was the video.
He made a video about this.
So you were in involved in that?
Yeah, I was in this video. Okay,
now I remember you. Okay. Yeah, I remember
you in that. It was a long time ago.
Long time.
Yeah.
Um, we, so we all went, we
all went to Bohemian Grove.
It was me and my producer, the
camera man. And then Alex and Alex,
his wife Violet and, and his friend
Mike. And it was like six of us.
And we were like strange bedfellows.
Oh,
this'll be fun, Alex. And
Alex was like, you know what?
At one point I said to Alex that
have you got like a contingency plan?
Like if we managed to get in and
like your, you know your uncovered,
have you got a contingency plan? And Alec
said yes and I said, what is it? He said,
I'll say to them,
don't get any closer.
And I'm like that's your contingency plan.
Don't get any gas like a threat.
I was growing up so is he was
just going to scare them? Yeah,
he's going to get any closer.
That's it. Don't get any closer.
That was Alex's plan. I don't think
he thinks that far ahead. Ah Shit.
That's a problem.
He really did put on robes and they
really do have like a bundle of sticks
that's supposed to represent a human
being and they carried it out there and
light it on fire. I saw it all
with my own eyes. What do they say?
That it represents a human being like,
well no,
what what they say is that
it represents dull cal,
like all the troubles in the world,
all these man of wealth and power
have all these troubles in the world.
I've got to say it was weird.
People problems for this
real first world problems.
Yeah. 1% are first world problems. Yeah.
We use that though.
We'll just have pain in the
ass for two weeks a year.
We'll just have so much stress.
We need to burn a fake person to make
you feel better. God you guys just,
it's so hard being a billionaire kind of.
How do you do it?
How do you run the world? I'll tell
you what was weird though. So Alex,
Alex is plan and this is how
we were going to get him.
We were going to rent a boat and like
say let along the river and then get out
and in climate the mountain and it get
down the other side and I get in that way.
I'm, I was thinking this is that
this is an ill conceived plan
and I know we met this
local lawyer called Rick.
He was like this preppy
lawyer who lived in the town,
Monte Rio Occidental and record had been,
and he infiltrated Bohemian Grove just
because like everybody in the town wants
to know what's going on in baby grove.
So we met Rick to get some tips on how
to break in and Alex told Rick is planned
and Rick said, look, if you go in that
way you're gonna get yourself killed.
And Alex wrote down,
I suppose my favorite,
one of my favorite bits
of the whole weekend,
Alex wrote down on this notepad
going in that way, dash killed.
So Rick said, well, you need to do is lie.
Go to Eddie Bauer and get yourself some
preppy clothes and just walk up the
drive. Just walk up the job.
[inaudible] that's a smart move. Yeah.
So Alex was like really
torn because part of him,
he admitted this to me afterwards.
Part of him was worried
that like in the wicker man,
me and Rick had all these other people
that we'd met with all part of this
cutoff elaborate plan to
Lou Alex into the forest.
So like he would,
oh that's so rich.
It crossed his mind.
So the upshot was that Alex
and Mike decided to go in
separately to me and Rick.
Oh yeah. So he didn't trust you that much?
No, he didn't trust he, I mean he didn't,
they didn't have Wikipedia back then.
He couldn't just Google your anything.
Right. Couldn't Google me. Um, did he know
of your work? Did he know who you were?
Not really. I, I wasn't
particularly well known back then.
I wasn't really well known.
Safe to say that Alex Jones
helped launch you.
We kind of help load teacher there
that night. You guys went in there
and Alex gave me this on VHS tape,
by the way,
back in 99 or whatever the hell you guys
actually made a tape out of it. Yeah.
Well Alex and I did this thing.
I did a special in Austin. Um,
my first DVD I filmed in Austin and
Alex and I dressed up as the bushes.
I was George Bush junior and he
was senior and we ran around the,
the, the state capitol with
like these Bush masks on. We,
I've seen that 52 let's have a
big bull horn saying that. Oh,
like satanist globalist at
one point in time. Definitely.
But I don't know if that made it into the
video, but we, he actually sang a song.
There's actually a song, I don't
know if we've ever played that song.
It's so ridiculous.
Alex Jones wrote a song about like the,
the elite and it,
it was on the video.
It was on the video and we're all like
dancing around to Alex Jones song in the,
in the,
it's a fucking stupid.
This is 99 99 or maybe
two. There it is. Yeah.
I, oh, what does he say? Look, put the
headphones on. You hear what he's saying?
I remember putting it back to the
beginning so we could hear it.
Oh,
that's me doing bong hits.
Are we sure as hell don't live ladies and
gentlemen from the belly of the beast.
Classic with the lies and disinformation.
No compromise.
One day closer to victory.
It's Joe Rogan Baby Shit.
I bought the Mass Moloch
and friends. So this is
old. This is your same time.
Know. I feel like Hayden Nip Shit. Alex,
is it adjusted Molec by
suggesting Bohemian Grove? Yeah,
the occasion I was wearing
a style project t shirt.
You remember style
project style project.com.
Oh flow.
That's Alex Jones Sagan.
He wrote it all too, by the
way. I ended up to do it though.
Oh my God, it was so stupid. And
the six, six, six of bushes head
I haven't met Alex said that weekend.
That's the only time you've
ever been in Waco. Waco first.
And then I lost touch with him after that.
He, he, he read can he liked me again?
Actually after I wrote the manifesto go,
it's like he didn't like me
after I wrote my book them,
which includes all this stuff
about sneaking into Bohemian
Grove cause he thought
I was too much of a
debunker of Bohemian Grove.
But then when I wrote
the metastatic goats,
he liked me again because
he felt that I was like, oh,
the minister it goes is kind of like a
conspiracy book in a way. Yeah. So, um,
how much different is it than the, should
we keep going with this Bohemian Grove?
Yeah. Yeah. It, there's more to say. Uh,
so Alex and Mike decided to
go and buy the undergrowth,
like I saw them. Um, so they
went in through the bushes.
They wouldn't see the bushes and
there was a lot of poison oak.
I wouldn't be at all. It's just walked
in. Yeah, man. Rick, the lawyer,
this kind of preppy lawyer. Um, oh,
tell me the funniest thing that
I've missed out of this story was,
was the night before we were
going to infiltrate, um,
Alex and Mike decided to
practice being preppy.
I'd said they were walking,
they were walking up and down like the
code or outside their Botero ribbed
talking in a kind of a feminine way
about microprocessors. Like, you know, I,
I just nanotechnologies the future.
Yeah.
That's how I think Doug
preppies die. Yeah. Oh,
uh, so, um, and then, so then
they went into the undergrowth.
Amedion and Rick, the lawyer went
up to drive, um, actually with,
with our producer John Surgeons and,
and just as Rick said, you know,
we gave the security guard to cat if I
ruled the world type wave. Um, we've just,
just preppy and we were in act like,
you know,
that's what it used to say when
you're used to rob things. I used to.
So just act like, you know, act like
you know what you're doing. Yeah.
We walked in and there was
this bank, my memories, okay,
there's this big bank of telephones.
This was that before cell phones were,
I guess there were cell phones,
but very fewer.
You have a few that was
a big bank of telephones.
And then there were all these camps.
It was like a giant redwood forest. Um,
and then there are all these little
camps everywhere and all the camps.
Sure enough,
had weird,
like almost definitely kind of
Maliyah la little red light.
I remember one of the campuses called
like devilized or something and it was
like little red eyes, you know,
poking out of the, think of it,
that car Halloween type type shit.
And then some of the camps had like
grand pianos and hot tubs and they'll all
these old men, all of whom looked like,
you know, Mr. Burns, um, sort of in,
in La little trucks going up and down.
Um,
and like the golf carts.
Yeah.
Sort of more like posh pickup trucks.
Let the kind of stuff you'd get like, like
a universal studio tools or something.
And then we saw, and there's like
all this owl stuff everywhere.
Now the reason love this,
some conspiracy theorists get really
annoyed with what I'm about to say. Um,
is that because everybody really loves
the idea that like they're worshiping
Molec the giant Devil Howell.
But the reason why I saw as I could tell,
they're all these owl
sculptures everywhere is cause
like, it's an owl sanctuary.
Like there's little cabins with
like stuffed owls in there.
It's like an owl sanctuary. So,
um, well wait a minute. There's,
there's,
it's an owl sanctuary,
like they actually take care of owls
or like an hour or preservation area.
Like this is a place where
owls nest. Oh No. Our legs.
So this is, if you were
worshiping an hour, God though,
wouldn't that be a cool place to make
your sanctuary where the owls actually
nest? Well, I guess so and less. You
can't totally debunk it there Mr. Ross.
Well that's true. An Oda wouldn't
like if you're worshiping a giant owl,
God wouldn't, or the regular sized.
I was be like false gods. I'm,
and I'm um,
Baskins maybe or you know,
I dunno if you have like a,
a great monkey God and the monkeys lived
around with a great monkey. God lived,
you'd feel like they worshiped the month.
I like their lip or shipped Moloch.
Okay, I'm with you on that
still. Nonetheless. The minions,
they did this bankable may,
I can tell you I have children.
So we were wondering about me and wreck.
Um,
and we saw this giant, the
giant Al Right. Um, of,
of everybody's life
legend. Um, it's funny,
I remember thinking it was stone,
but then a few years later somebody
else infiltrated Bohemian Grove for some
magazine and said,
it's not stone,
it's like plaster of Paris
or word or something. But,
and I'm sure that right when
you guys were far away from it,
I remember spending like all the way
up to it. So is there a security guard?
Like when you walked down,
there was one guy sitting in a little
hut and he didn't ask anything,
didn't ask anything. He just wait, like
enjoy, enjoy your evening or something.
And where is Bohemian grow? Yeah, what
state? It's in northern California. It's,
it's next to this little town called
Occidental. It's like a no through roads.
And then he'd go up the road.
A north of San Francisco. Yeah,
north of Napa is north
of Napa. Okay. Hmm. Uh,
and um, I remember seeing Alex and
Mike and I was like, well, hey,
it's Alex and mark. Hey, I did. They
walked past and they said, keep walking.
That's how it was everywhere.
It's commerce at the chase
is our walls everywhere else.
Mike said it's how was
everywhere today see out?
I mean they talk a little bit what
hours or what? I think at this point,
Mike was convinced that every time they
saw an hour and it was like, you know,
it was molec relate to, she's
just fucking crushed. Yeah. So,
so what were you thinking at this point?
You're thinking,
what the fuck have I got myself
into hanging out with these guys?
They're going to ruin my
whole investigation? Well,
no, I mean I was nervous, um,
because you know, um, the closer you can
get those microphone, the better tools.
We don't have our heads hearts. So
yeah, I was Kinda, I was nervous. Um,
but I sort of thought it was kind of
fun. I felt safe with Rick, the lawyer.
I felt like nothing bad would happen
to me because he looked so rich and
prepping and that's like every
horror movie where things go bad.
You're hanging out with Rick, the lawyer.
Yeah. I thought I'd be fine with Rick.
The lawyer.
Yeah.
So then the bell rings like gets
to dusk and as a rigging of the,
and if all these old men like drift down
to this little pond and they all sit on
like grass,
one side of the pond and I,
and Alex and Mike are there like a few
rows behind us and there's the giant owl
on the other side of the pond.
Um,
I remember this moment was,
I thought it was really weird
was this old man comes up to me.
I mean this is like nearly 20 years ago,
so I don't remember like
all of the details, but,
but this old man came up to me and said
something lie like I was way younger
than everybody else there and this.
And this guy says to me,
is this your first time? And I said,
yeah. I said, Oh, you're going to love it,
a burn and burn em.
And I did the sort of impression of
what was about to happen in, in the,
in the pageant.
And there was this look of like real
fucking intensity on this guy's face.
And at that moment I thought to myself
like there's Alex and Mike like a few
rows behind me,
convinced that this is like evidence
that the global or liter blood drinking
satanists.
And then there's all these like men of
wealth and power who are really fucking
into it all themselves.
And they might be into it in a different
way to the way Alex and micro into it,
but they're fucking into it.
And I thought,
I'm the only sane person in this
entire fucking redwood worked.
The lawyer and Rick,
me and Rick were the only same people.
I wonder if for 10 has dropped off from
that place, wants to invented Viagara,
you know, just like rich old
dudes and they couldn't get it up.
It's not a lot to do
your board. Yeah, it was,
it was a weird way to
spend your summer vacation.
I didn't see any like famous people,
but at one point we pass
this law display cabinet.
I know with the names of the guests
on the, in, in the display cabinet,
and I remember seeing Dick
Cheney's name. Oh yeah. For sure.
That's probably gets us
extra hearts. Yeah. Have you
ever, uh, there's a photo of,
I think it's Ronald Reagan at
Bohemian Grove. Yeah. We might
pull that up Jamie.
Cause it's a crazy photo.
So this has been like a weird spot
where these guys have gone for decades.
Well since I guess since like the
railroad came through San Francisco, like,
like, you know, the turn
of the 20th century.
I think that's pretty much
when it started. All the fuck
started. This theater is,
there's Nixon,
there's ran who started this thing
and look at the big redwood behind on
something majestic tree. Yeah. Okay.
What I, what I heard, and as I say,
it's been like 20 years since I've
thought about this stuff too much because
once I put it in them, I kind
of forgot about it. But, but,
but the story I heard was the,
when the railroad was coming
through San Francisco,
all the rich white Republicans
and unlike Bilderberg, this is,
have a Republican club, uh, thought, you
know, fuck, there goes the neighborhood,
you know,
we're going to lose our elite status.
We need to set up a
private club for ourselves.
So they set up the Bohemian Club in San
Francisco and then Bohemian Grove and
you know,
if a couple of hours north.
So then this less ritual starts this,
you see a man wearing later Hosan appears
in like a stage cut out of the giant
redwoods and he's got like leaves all
over his later hose and it's like leaf
covered later hose and he
starts singing this like and,
and the symphonies there,
like the San Francisco symphony.
Well there's a video of it pull,
pull,
pull a video of Alex Jones at
Bohemian Grove because Alex,
Alex was a few rows behind us and he was
filming it or like with a camera that
had toppled over 45 degrees. It is, it is
bag and yeah, he filmed the whole thing.
Yeah, he did it like on a
sneak tip. Yeah, I did it.
Film is early as like,
like the pre show later
hose and I don't know
if I know Alex. Yeah. Alex. He felt
everything and put everything out.
Um,
see if you can find just some dude in
a row in front of a giant fucking owl.
Yeah. So yes, it's toppled
over sideways. Yeah.
So go full screen.
Maybe we'll get a better look at it.
And I'm a few Rosen from yeah. So
then this happens, all these men in,
in robes and hoods or descend,
um,
infant of the giant owl that you go area.
And they have this ritual where,
where this puppy and Masha effigy
like comes out over on the pond, um,
in a Gondola and they say twitch,
you know, we shall burn here tonight.
A Dole care and then the voice
of dog care, cause he showed up,
burn me and then I go year after year.
Dot thing year after year and this
happy grove, we burned the um,
and then they lifted up and
throw in the fire and the,
and the FTE goes that that makes noises.
Do they have like a speaker system
or something? Yes, he's the speakers.
And what you can't see in the videos that,
that there's an orchestra
a to your left a bit.
Fuck knows where the guy in the lift
covered later host and gone at this
juncture. But he was on, he was like
basically sitting on the giant redwood.
He's getting sodomized by
Nixon and Dick Cheney. Yeah.
Ronald Reagan's coaching them.
There's probably about a
thousand people in that crowd,
the other side of the pond.
Wow. When the fireworks go off,
you get like a glimpse of
how many people there are.
There's probably a thousand people.
Wow. Now one of the requirements,
like how do you get in there?
You get invited.
I met Harry sharer who got invited
Harry Shearer from the Simpsons.
He was the only person who'd
been to Bohemian Grove who
was willing to like talk
about it to me like after we left
and he said he was invited to,
these were his words.
He said he was invited to do the
place up like the word juice.
And he said he thought
it was kinda ridiculous,
but he agreed with my
interpretation of it,
which is basically that it's not
evidence that the secret rulers,
the world are actually,
um,
satanists who do actual human sacrifice,
which is basically the way Alex was.
We're spinning it,
but it's this kind of
weird overblown pageant.
Um,
what I think is really interesting,
and I think this is where
skull and bones comes into it,
is that there is this weird proclivity
amongst the elites to create these
ancient ceremonies for themselves.
And none of them are actually ancient.
They're all only what,
like a hundred years old at the most,
but there do not for a reason,
right?
They want to create this cut and
masonic ritualistic, you know,
Maliyah for themselves. And I think
there's a weird psychology going on there.
Cause I've been new or me, we were, well,
I mean I wouldn't, you wouldn't. No,
I wouldn't. Yeah, I might. I would
have to be really fucked up to do it,
to be under the influence of a
lot of different things. But the,
the idea behind it I guess is that you,
you get closer if you're all doing
this ridiculous shit together,
that somehow or another through
tradition or through a ritual that you,
you bond,
you bound him and maybe it gives you
a kind of mandate to be in an elite.
I sometimes wonder whether
lack of skull and bones too.
It's not just about bonding,
but it's also about creating this
kind of specialness for yourself.
Right, right, right. Yeah. That
gives you a sort of, you know,
does it make you feel so,
so insecure about the idea that you're
a global elitist is ruling the world.
What's the other thing about
skull and bonds as well?
There were saying that
the part of the ritual,
they do like really humiliating shit to
each other and they film it so that they
always have this like
undecided Telogis maybe.
Yeah, I'm, yeah, I've heard
I've heard that, but I, but I,
but I don't know if that's true,
but I've heard that,
well young Jamie was saying the Tom
Cruise might be leaving Scientology.
Is there any evidence to
support this star Star magazine?
Well, that's about as good as it gets.
The body. I'll be good. It's going.
Claire has a lot of power, I think
the movement, well it certainly did.
I mean it exposed, it will what it
all deals with. I think with this,
this Bohemian Grove thing and is
this sort of a cultish mindsets,
these weird sort of mindsets where they
engage in otherwise preposterous rituals
that to the outside or like to
us like we're watching this hour,
God and I'll fucking bundle
of sticks and burn the,
this is so fucking stupid.
But to those people,
it represents this thing that they've
all kind of agreed to do this goofy shit
together and there's some weird power
in that. Yeah, I agree with that.
It's,
it's definitely there for a reason.
What exists in so many different cultures.
That's the weirdest part about it.
It's like you go back to like the
Aztecs and the Maya, like they would,
they would make these human sacrifices.
They would wear these crazy outfits and
plumed head dresses and it was all this
like, yeah, it took us more than
the isis cause to, sure. Yeah. Yeah.
But it's bizarre the out when people
start wearing outfits and engaging in
rituals, you know, that's the,
that's a weird aspect of human behavior
that seems to be really prevalent.
It's like, it's not like
an isolated incidence where
there's only this, you know,
like if you go to Africa and you
see like a or Asia or you know,
you see like these people that have those,
those things that extend their neck,
those little bars, those
women put, they're like, God,
what are they doing? What's,
it's very isolated.
Yeah.
It's only like one group of people
that do it or so the women that put the
plates that this surgery,
women that put the plates in their lips,
like what the fuck is that? It doesn't
catch on. It doesn't go anywhere else.
Like bizarre ritual, but it's only
isolate this one very specific area,
but rituals themselves,
like really wacky dresses and the
weird things that people do. It's,
it's so common.
It's almost like every culture has
them on the people involved. Um,
by the way, when my book them came out,
the Bohemian club made a statement.
I remember about my book where they say,
they said something along the lines of,
despite Jon Ronson's
objectionable chest passing,
we appreciate the fats that he's putting
a less kind of sensation lists spin on
what he saw then what Alex Jones does.
And so they kind of appreciated
the fact that I was,
I was being less hysterical about it
than Alex and they said, you know, it's,
it's overblown,
it's an overblown pageants,
but it couldn't be more innocent or
something along those lines. That's it.
To a squire. And by the way, he could
definitely be more innocent. I mean, look,
the Mickey Mouse parade at Disneyland
is also an overblown pageant and that
could not be more innocent.
It's not,
that's really literally
as innocent as things get.
Blaming Grove could be way more innocent.
You're, you're burning someone like,
and you're saying I burned the,
and then you have screams that play out
over a loudspeaker that's not innocent.
That's Wacky as fuck. Like it's hard
to just, just stating the facts.
It would be really hard to soften that up.
You know,
like saying that you have an over
sensationalized version of it. Like what?
That's not possible. Like
it's really sensational. Oh,
the saying that I
definitely had some chuck,
this is why me and Alex fell out because
I felt what we saw was bizarre enough
without having to put a spin on it.
What was Alex Suspense? Onyx has been,
was Pratt to clay that,
you know,
it's possible that they were killing
an actual baby. I mean, attics,
I come to find out about that, but
he, well he bought it a long way. Oh,
how did what he, uh, at one
point he said to me, yeah,
we overheard these two old men. Like when
we were walking down the road. I mean,
it's to the,
me and Alex were like,
you know, but he said at one point we
overheard these two old man going, yeah,
we're going to get him elected.
And I thought like,
I don't know that Alex didn't hear that,
but that's a bit fucking convenience.
I thought that's exactly what the thing
Alex would want to hear at Bohemian
Grove. Oh, knows what that
conversation was about.
I take something out of context like that.
It could have been a total complete joke.
It could have been elected
to let the local shrine has,
it could've been anything.
And the boys house cause I mean who knows
what the fuck they were talking about.
Alex is one of those
jumped to conclusions,
confirmation bias characters that
oftentimes has some really fascinating
information. Uh, and as much I admired
that. Alex, I mean he's a good friend,
a good friend. He's an
extraordinary broadcasters. Crazy.
He's crazy. He's my friend. I'll tell
you right now. He's, I was fucking mind,
but he's right a lot of the time.
I mean one of the best pieces of work
that Alex did was nine one one the road to
tyranny.
And in that he exposed some stuff from
news broadcast that was really shocking
about the use of agent provocateurs too,
which I always thought
was utter horse shit.
And then it turns out not
only is it not horse shit,
but it's standard operational
procedure has been proven. Um,
with this occupy Wall Street crowd.
They infiltrated the occupy Wall Street
group and did all kinds of crazy shit
and the park, we're trying to get
people to join them and arrest them.
And what the agent provocateurs did
during the WTO protest is they would,
um,
they had these peaceful protests and they
would come in dressed up and like all
black and they had military issue boots
and they were smashing windows and
breaking things.
And then they gave an excuse for the
cops come in and close down the protest.
Well, they literally set up, I know,
protest zone where people couldn't
go to work with WTO badges.
They had a WTO badge with us aligned
through it, like saying no WTO.
They were literally telling them they
couldn't go to work with that on cause
they know protest like a fucking pin,
like,
which is completely against everything
in this country is supposed to stand for.
Right. And so these people
were, um, you know, they,
these agent provocateurs or working for
the government and they literally came
in to try to break up up a peaceful
protest by turning it violent.
And then they were all held up in this
one house and Alex documented at all,
not with his own news footage
and his own reporting spin,
but basically just using actual news
stories and different coverages by
different local news stations and showed
like what the fuck actually went on.
These people were all released,
these guys were all held up in a building
somewhere and they negotiated their
release. Someone did
somehow and it, you know,
at first I was really super
skeptical because I was like,
that sounds like nonsense. But
then you, the more you peel away,
the more you realize, oh well this is
something that they've always done.
It's like a standard look,
if you've got a bunch of people that
are protesting and they're ruining your
elite, globalist fun, like the best
way to do it if they're being peaceful,
is to have people that pretend to be
amongst them start smashing things.
Then you have an excuse to come in and
arrest everybody. And that's what they do,
man. So he, he, he had a really
fascinating video on that,
showing evidence of that being used
before that there's a bunch of tactics are
in place places not simply as innocent
as that law enforcement is set up to
enforce laws and to preserve
peace. It's not, it's not they,
they do do a bunch of creepy
shit. And you know, that's,
that's unfortunate. But that's when you
start talking about conspiracy theory.
Well that seems to be conspiracy fact,
you know,
it just seems to be something that's
standard operational procedure when they
can get away with it.
What I'm hoping is that with all this
wikileaks shit and all this Edward Snowden
stuff and all the, the, the new details
that had been revealed about the NSA and,
and what we know now about security and
the Internet and the cloud and it's,
everything can be hacked.
Everything can be compromised.
I'm hoping that all goes away because
I'm hoping that it's just can be way too
transparent. But you know, I dunno,
but Alex Jones thinks they're,
what they're trying to do is
get down to 500,000 people.
He's got this idea in his
head. Yeah. 500,000 people.
These really grandiose
things. He says like, God,
Deity think he really believes them.
Do you think he's like,
like he's trying to make something that's
so huge that everyone's going to like
Jordan's house towards him.
Um, he's not a liar. Um, he,
he might go further with
things then I would,
you know,
he might not have rational conclusions.
He might approach things
with confirmation bias.
But when you spend five hours a day
on the fucking radio or whatever,
he does just going over a wacky
theories and selling gold,
gold and bonds and dried foods,
they got dried food.
Keep the dried fruit and your basement.
You know,
after a while I think you
lose your fucking mind.
And if you work at a strip club,
you get sick or hookers.
He gets sick of working with
strippers. You know, if you're,
you're selling drugs all day, the last
thing you want to do is take trucks.
I think Alex is like
inundated with conspiracy.
It's like he's overwhelmed.
You know,
you probably can't see the forest for
the trees. It's just saw chaos to him.
It's all everybody's in on it.
It's still the global elite people are
turning into reptiles left and right.
Burning owls, babies whenever
they can. I don't know man.
I don't, I mean you'd have to ask her.
I love the guy though. He's a great guy.
I love hanging out with him.
He's a lot of fun.
We had week we got on better again,
as I said,
after the metastatic coats came out,
cause he really,
he liked that book and then he had me
on his show and then like all of his
listeners said I was a shale for the
road or do they how Michelle too?
Sometimes they say that. It
depends. Depends on what I say.
When I was talking about chem trails,
then they got really mad at me.
Joe Rogan's a shale.
I debunk chem trails.
Didn't even debunk.
I just fucking science.
I mean it's like real simple science
behind what happens when a jet engine
passes through condensation in the
atmosphere. It's like it's been,
they've known about it for fucking ever
this idea that they're spraying clouds.
Like what the fuck? Man that they're
controlling you with these clouds.
But when I did this a Scifi show,
we talked about it and you know I brought
in aviation specialists and I talked
to different scientists and I talked to
a bunch of different people about it and
you know what?
We decided to print wa or we decided
to show on the television show.
Unfortunately you're doing with
44 minutes of TV for an hour.
You know you've got a bunch of different
commercial so it kind of you don't
spend, I think to really
debunk something like that.
You'd have to kind of like spend a long
time with it and actually show people
like actually get a jet up in the
air and film it and show how this,
this plane is actually leaving these
clouds because it's passing through.
Hayes wouldn't be too hard to do
if you had a really good budget,
but we didn't have really good budget
and it wouldn't be that entertaining.
And then we had to make it
like short little snippets,
which is like a real issue when you're
dealing with any of those debunking shows
is that they also have to be entertaining
and they also have to fit within a
format where they have to
break every five minutes,
whatever it is for commercials.
What is that,
how seven minutes or something like that.
Whatever the fuck they do, you know,
they're,
they're constantly having commercials.
So it's like you have to have these
little tiny chunks of information and it's
really just entertainment
more than anything.
Say No, I don't, I don't see myself
as a debunker because I think, um,
yeah, what I saw it behaved been growth
for instance, was, was really, it was odd.
There was a kind of intensity there,
which,
which I believe is very different
to what Alex felt was going on,
but it was still odd. Yeah.
Well, it's undeniably odd, right?
I mean it is odd. Yeah. I, yeah,
and rituals exists for a reason.
And one reason is that though, I
mean, I don't know for certain, but I,
but I would say it's this idea,
you know, you know, we love to, um,
this is a bit of a non sequitur,
but my most recent book is this
book about public shaming codes.
So you've been publicly shamed.
And what I've noticed happens on Twitter,
it is,
is we will,
we will reduce somebody to a label,
will reduce somebody to the
worst tweet that they ever wrote.
We'll demonize them and
then we'll dehumanize them
because we've just destroyed
somebody's and we don't want to
feel bad about destroying them.
So we called them like a sociopath or
something. It says this, his whole life,
mental trick we play on ourselves.
Uh, like, um, what's it called?
Cognitive dissonance.
This idea that we're good people,
but we've just destroyed some of the day.
So how do we make sense of that?
Or we just say, or without a sociopath
or something. So it was all about,
it's all about labeling and reducing and,
and demonizing
and destroying people that we don't like.
And it's also about having an
excuse to be a real asshole re,
all you have to do is find a reason why
you can only share a fury on people.
And it's a free shot.
It's a free shot because of John
Ronson says something fucked up.
There's a million people that could find
out about that and they don't know you
at all. And so they have a free
shot. They'd never met you.
They're never going to meet you,
meet you.
They live in another part of the planet
and they could just steam faking,
fuck that guy. They can just
start typing a bunch of shit.
And it's this weird thing going on,
what have you,
but he's kidded themselves
into believing that, you know,
you can lead a good ethical life.
Like I can lead a good ethical life,
but some bad phrasiology in a tweet or
something could be a clue to alis secret
in an evil. Yeah. What? You're
really, really back. Yeah.
And I just wonder whether there's
some kind of connection between,
it's about color, you know,
between that and about, um,
the rituals that you find at
places like Bohemian Grove.
And maybe the connection is that it's all
about tricking yourself into believing
that you can do evil shit.
So like would you give yourself like a
ritual it skull and bones or Bohemian
Grove that makes you feel,
oh,
I'm separate and different and better
and that gives me a mandate to rule the
world. I could inflict this cottage and
other people because I different to them.
I'm better than them.
And maybe on Twitter we do the same thing
and other little ways, which is like,
oh well,
you know,
we're better than that person because
that person just just misuse their
privilege. So that person just, just,
you know, showed that true in an evil.
It's all about kind of,
it's all about setting yourself apart
from people so that you can behave in, in,
in ways that hurt other people.
And you don't have to feel bad about it.
Maybe that's the connection.
Well,
people have a tendency to pile on.
It's always been the case. That's
the reason why you, you see,
like when riots break out that that
sort of exploits that type of pile on
behavior.
People will do things in large
groups of chaotic moments,
like large groups of chaos.
Rather they would,
they would never do with an individual,
you know,
as far as like assaulting people or I
mean there's been instances where uh,
gangs of people beat up and killed
people and the people that were involved
almost didn't feel responsible because
they were one of many that stomp somebody
or kick somebody or went over somebody's,
this snowflake doesn't need
to feel responsible for the
avalanche. Yeah, exactly.
That's a great way of putting it.
And I think diffusion of responsibility
is a real issue with human beings when
it comes to large numbers. Uh,
anytime there's large numbers,
they don't feel responsible for any
repercussions are of their actions.
If there was only two
people in the world and to,
people in the world were somehow or
another invented Twitter and they were
communicating with each other.
And One guy, uh, you know,
said something questionable and the,
the other guy quoted him and said,
John Ronson is a piece of shit. Here
is proof. You know, fuck this guy.
Let's shame him. What's this? Let's
is only you does it, you know,
there's no one there.
But what you're trying to do is they're
appealing to the bully instinct of
people to just pile on.
And I'm torn because sometimes I think
publicly shaming people is a good thing.
Like if it's actual social
justice to rights and wrongs.
But the problem is,
I think these days we're in this really
bad situation where people have decided
to not differentiate between a serious
transgression and an unserious challenge
points. And some nice liberal person
who tells a joke that comes out badly,
is treated with a similar
level of ferocity.
It's like a racist cop from the
McKinney Texas video. Well, most the,
that's a very good way of putting it.
I think most people are not living life,
even they're going through life with
a deficit and they started out with is
devastated by having a bunch of fucking
shitty experiences when they were
children.
They're shitty parents and bad time in
school and maybe they'd been picked on
and maybe their job socks or maybe they
have unfulfilled sexual expectations.
Whatever the fuck it is.
Most people are going
into any situation with a,
a headwind or a tailwind, I guess it
is when someone, something behind you,
Pale ones, right? Tailwind,
the headwind is your drive.
There's push behind them,
but they're like accelerates their
reaction to anything and they're almost
looking for something that they
can blame their bad feeling on it.
Almost looking for a target to unleash
all there an existential angst and
frustration and life.
All their unfulfilled expectations.
All of it is on John Ronson.
Shitty tweet, you know,
and I wish he stopped and easy to direct.
I'm sorry,
I'll just fuck someone else.
Um,
but I've experienced it
before. I have experienced,
but I've, I found it adorable.
I would retweet people and
stuff when they did it to me.
But what I always liked to,
I noticed cause after my public shaming
book came out, obviously you know a lot,
there was a lot of pushback and a lot of
people went for me and I always really
liked it when people went from me in a
kind of a ridiculous way cause that could
retweet that one.
It would make me look good.
I know it was one of
my favorite one was um,
all these people started like going
for me and one person wrote why and I
wasn't,
I just stayed completely silent.
And one person wrote why some John and
applying to any of us and somebody else
wrote because John Watson under applies
to men and I'm not, fuck does that mean,
yeah, honestly like I'm like,
I'm so upset at you for ah,
um, s wow, okay. Well in
that particular instance,
um, it all started with
Justine sacco. I wrote,
there's a chapter in my book
that's defends Justine Sacco,
who's the AIDS tweet woman.
Remember on the plane, listen man,
that lady is probably on Xanax and wine
and she said something that she thought
was funny. That would be funny if she was
your friend. I like to be funny if she,
well she was my friend and she told me
she sent that to me in a text message.
I would fucking laugh. Yeah. You know, I'm
going to Africa, hope I don't get aids.
Lol. Just kidding. I'm white.
Yeah. And then the worst thing it,
then she gets on the plane.
Yeah. She gets on the plane,
turns off her phone while she's asleep
is like just tailored to shreds by like
16 hours,
hundreds of thousands of people.
And one of the most extraordinary
things about it is that her inability to
explain herself became part
of the hilarity. That was,
that was the tailwind. Like,
oh my God, we know something.
She doesn't. One person tweeted,
we're about to watch this Justine sacco
bitch get fired in real time before she
even knows she's being fired.
And I just kinda think of anything
more unjust than that. So,
so I wrote this really passionate,
you know, polemic defending her.
I think that, you know, we had gone crazy,
we'd lost our minds and they said it
was the most in judicial thing you could
possibly think of.
And a lot of people,
if you can imagine kind of really
objected to that. So of course,
cause they have the green light to object.
I mean it's not that you're not
saying something reasonable.
I thought it was one of the most important
stores I ever did because like for,
for 30 years I've been
writing about abuses of power.
Like in the psychopath test,
they're pieces of power in the
pharmaceutical industry or, or you know,
the worst excesses of psychiatry or
psychopaths. So whatever, whatever,
the people abusing their power over there.
And whenever I like gave talks about
that, I'd like to, whom we'd love her,
you know, people would love it.
And then I write this new story,
this new book where I say,
you know what?
The people are abusing our
power now that they're us.
It's like we've suddenly got all this
new power of Twitter and social media and
we're massively abusing it.
And the pushback is ferocious because
the pushback is from the very people who
enjoyed abusing his power. Yeah. Yeah.
I have been talking about this for a
while and I think that what's going on now
with with people and
the Internet and this,
this new found ability to communicate
that we find ourselves in this new found
situation we find ourselves in where
anyone instantaneously can comment on
virtually anything that
happens in the world.
And if what you say resonates or offense,
it can become a hot button and it just
like gets all these ants just find the
sugar and they just dive on it and
they just swarm and it's almost like a
mindless thing because I think that what
we're experience is an adolescent stage
of a new level of communication that
human beings are experiencing. Yeah.
I think that this new level
of communication is starting
off with the ability to
just tweet at each other and it's going
to eventually go into some weird virtual
reality place that's and lets people
filet, you know my friend Colleen? Yeah.
A couple of years ago,
my friend Adam Curtis,
cause actually flip phones
and live in the desert. Well,
cut your own woods in the,
basically
I found out from curse, he said to
me, uh, who you'd love by the way,
if you don't know his stuff, he knows,
Oh God, you'd love him. He made, um,
the power of nightmares and the century
of the southeast great doc, BBC. Dot.
Yeah. And we, Adam said to
me one time that, you know,
he thinks that the internet or definitely
social media is going to be like one
of those John Carpenter movies from the
80s where everybody's yelling at each
other and everyone's like killing each
other and eventually everyone flees to
somewhere safer like the suburbs. And
maybe that's because I do, you know,
I noticed myself feeling a bit from
social media. So we're talking about,
yeah, I, I never, I, I
when a long time ago,
maybe 10 years ago or so, um, I would
argue with people online all the time.
And then I realized what an
enormous waste of time and is also,
I realized that I'm not picking the people
that I communicate with as opposed to
the way you do it in real life.
And one of the things that I would do in
real life is I would avoid anybody that
starts arguments in a shitty all the time.
People were insulting and Shitty.
I would argue, I wouldn't argue
with them, I would avoid them.
But on the Internet I would like
engage these people, you know,
and like I'll get you, yeah
you fucking loser, you know?
But you realize after a while like,
oh,
this is a new thing
and I'm applying to it.
Like the sort of same strategy that I
would apply to a heckler at a comedy club
and you really can't,
like this is it,
this is a totally new thing and no one
knows how to do it yet is we, we, we,
we don't have the benefit of hindsight
to be able to step in. And you know,
we're talking like 2000 2001 we didn't
have the benefit of stepping back and
saying, well this has been going on for
a long time and now we understand how to,
how to deal with people.
But back then we didn't
and I wasted a lot of time,
had some fun but wasted a lot of time.
And also you,
you get emotionally charged up and
invested in these people that in real life
you probably wouldn't want to hang out
with them pulling up the amaze folks to
be with.
They are. And, and just the Internet
is turning us into, you know,
he's an empathetic psychopathic
figures. I mean, you know,
maybe from that and the new life
that beast, that'd be sweet.
Well you wouldn't know them first of all
based on their tweets because a tweet
is one of the worst representations
of you. Yeah, it's good.
It has to be kind of extreme
hundred and 40 characters. I mean,
sometimes it can be poignant.
Sometimes he can be funny,
but like to sum you up from first of all,
to sum you up by your writing is difficult
enough as it is when you're writing
chapters in paragraphs
without any back and forth.
It's hard because I don't think we
are just who we are as an individual.
I think we,
we are,
we are who we are based on who we're
interacting with and how that works out.
Like that's who you really are.
That's one of the things
that's so important about
choosing your friends because
your friends aren't just someone you
enjoy that kind of help define you.
And when you have a bunch of
really good friends and you,
you communicate with them well and get
a lot out of it, it changes who you are.
You become a better person. You
can give, become a better person,
a really good relationship and you
can become an awful person in a bad
relationship. You know, I've been in bad
relationships before. I didn't like me.
I'm like, this person hates me. I
don't even like me anymore. Like what?
What the fuck is going on?
And it's because we're, we,
we like to think of ourselves
as completely autonomous,
but I don't think that's real.
I don't think there's anybody
that's really autonomous.
I think we all need
human beings and we all,
we all cherish human interaction.
As much as you want privacy,
you don't want it all the time.
I mean,
if you had to choose between no privacy
or no people, I would take no privacy.
Every time I like people, the
people are great, you know,
I don't want to be bothered all the time
and that's when people will think the
woods seem like a great idea.
I'm just going to go unibomber and
just fucking live in the woods. But no,
you don't. You don't
want to do that. Like we,
we literally are a super organism.
We are not like one individual
experiencing the universe
solely on our own where
we are all constantly
interacting with each other.
Yeah. Which I think is part of the
reason by social, by social media,
public shaming is so fucking traumatizing
to somebody on the receiving end is
nothing, you know, to be a to B,
two B ejected from society to be told you
not as good as everybody else does get
out is like deeply traumatizing.
But then the people doing the shaming,
they don't want to think that. They
don't really think that they've just, um,
potentially done something intensely
traumatizing to another human being that
mangled up somebodies mental
health. So they just think,
oh, I'm sure they're fine.
You know, I'm sure that fire,
that person who just showed
up. Sure, they're fine. Um,
um, you know, there's a guy, uh,
please dyadic Gorka who reviewed my
book in one of the papers who basically
said, oh, John Watson. So sweet. You know,
it's fine. You know, if you, if you're
a man being publicly shamed, it's fine.
It's no big deal. They're just fine. And
then I was looking at this as thinking,
fucking hell. You know, I've, I've gone
around the world, meet these people.
They're not,
they are not fucking fine.
Is that whether you want to
carry on doing it or not,
you have to accept they are
not fine. You know, people,
well,
a few weeks after that guy wrote that
review some guy in Israel who had been
falsely accused of being racist,
uh, committed suicide. Uh,
you know, they're not fine. It's that
you can carry on doing it if you want,
but it's a really severe
fucking punishment.
Well, this mob mentality has
existed throughout history. I mean,
when you go back to,
uh,
the punishing of the witches in
Salem or would they do in Africa,
have you ever seen the,
these,
these witchcraft accusation things in
Africa where one person will tell someone
that someone's a witch and then everybody
else in the tribe believes it and
they're burning people.
This is really disturbing
videos,
but it's like this pile on where I
think part of what's going on is,
is a real fear of that same
thing could happen to them.
And so they lash out that
one person like with,
with real commitment so that they're
inextricably a part of the group.
They're in that group.
They're safe for that day because we
can only handle destroying one person.
And I notice with just 10 soccer,
one person that night tweeted,
somebody's HIV positive should rape this
bitch and then we'll find out if her
skin color protects her from aids.
And you know how many people went after
that person? No one is like we would to,
everyone was too excited about destroyed.
Just stayed to simultaneously destroy
somebody who was at appropriately
destroyed. Just aids it up. Has it got
a fucking total free pass that night.
I imagine the mindset of someone to
think that the best way to respond to
someone's inappropriate joke is to rape
them and give them an incurable deadly
disease. I just in, I let feel
totally justified doing it.
I'm Justine was asleep
out of fucking play.
I everyone and everyone knew that and
that's why everyone loved it so much.
Well didn't she write a bunch of other
ridiculous tweets like that was what she
was trying to be. Twitter?
Yeah. I mean it was a few.
I had that one was I had a sex dream
about an autistic kid last night.
I didn't know it was something about,
you know, it's just stupid shit. Um,
I bet she's fun to drink with.
Yeah.
When I had a couple of drinks so she
wasn't fun the first time cause she was so
fucking crushed.
It just a couple of weeks late,
probably took years off of her life. Oh
Jesus. Poor GST. Um, the second time,
was she okay. Better the second time
and it took her a year. It was a year.
She was basically recover.
Yeah.
She was basically fucked and in the
wilderness for a year, you know,
a notice actually after my book came out,
one of the pushbacks was like,
well, you know, just in
soccer is fine now. You know,
she was only like unemployed on, you
know, deeply traumatized for a year.
And I'm like, for one fucking
joke that [inaudible] a year,
you know. Oh my God. Yeah. Well that joke
was representative of the hardest part.
Yeah. Is that this is what we
fucking do. And it's such a lie.
It's like we're all these
fucking Miss Marples,
all these amateur sleuths I'd social
media thinking that we can spot somebody
true inner evil to a
little bit of phrasiology.
That's what happened to Trevor Noah.
And it just happens over and over and uh,
and it's actually Amy Schumer and it
just happens over and over and over again
with Amy Schumer and Trevor Noah though
their standups, and especially Amy.
Amy doesn't give a fuck.
Like you can't,
that she gives a bit more of a fuck
then I just think everybody who's at the
receiving end of that, it does, but
it gives her an out, first of all,
she doesn't ever say anything that is
indefensible because she's very smart.
And also I think as a comic,
everything that she says,
that's ridiculous. Um, if you
want to debate her on like,
why are not,
I mean she plays the role of a dumb person
saying ridiculous shit all the time.
Like that's part of like a persona that
she'll adopt and abandoned on stage.
She'll adopt it and abandoned and you
know, going in, that's what she's doing.
It's a part of being
entertaining. It's like, you know,
a Richard Pryor doing the
dopey white guy voice.
Do I think he's really Adobe white
guy now when he's like, hey my mom,
she's a great old Gal. No, he's
doing the fucking character of a,
a dopey person. It's easy to mock this.
The same thing that Amy does when she's,
she might not change her voice, but
when she says ridiculous shit, she's,
she's clearly being a comic and doing
it as an art form. Right. You know, so
she can move through a few times on
your podcast by the way. And, and uh,
that in a little while. Right. But
she's been, she's got her show.
I haven't talked to her forever.
She's busy as fuck.
She's got that movie coming out. But,
uh, she's very smart. She's very smart.
And so she would welcome any opportunity
to defend anything like that.
She doesn't take herself like ridiculously
seriously or anything like that.
She's very smart girl.
But I fitness as a really woman
wouldn't want her calling me a boy.
I think it's,
there's like a serious change going on
in the way that human beings act towards
you. So do you like it? No, I think
it's really bad. It's stressful.
Who would have thought? The
public shaming part? Yeah.
I mean what I do like is the fact that
there's a leveling of the playing field
and social justice is, you know, obviously
that side of things I really liked. But,
but the problem is, you know, is that the,
I think the problem I tell you it is like
I would call it in London, in the ATS,
and sometimes I feel with social media
and with the social justice movement,
it's like the worst fucker
who used to hang around.
The student union now
gets to decide everything.
And it's partly because of like the
hundred and 40 character Twitter thing.
So basically,
you know,
in the student union in the 1980s
we all cared about social justice,
but it's like the most unforgiving extreme
fucker is now the one who's actually
setting the agenda and not only
setting the agenda on social media,
but because the mainstream media is so
enthralled to social media and doesn't
want to get hurt. So it goes along
with it. It's kind of critic,
an entire society of, of, of
a surveillance society and
colleges are where people first start
exercising that muscle and it's the most
rabid version of this issue today.
It's one of the reasons why
a lot of Comedians won't
perform in colleges anymore.
Jerry Seinfeld just got a hard time from
a bunch of people because he said that
colleges are too politically correct
and Chris rock has seen the same thing.
And I stopped doing colleges a long
fucking time ago for the very same reason.
Yeah, well I did a college once and
this is a perfect example of it,
but this is a guy,
this,
this example is perfect because
this is before the Internet. Um,
and this was a guy that I actually talked
to face to face. Like someone said,
uh, you know, like I would do colleges
and I'd fly into these towns and you know,
their board.
So like I'd tell my jokes and then
sometimes I do look Q and a with them.
You know, just for fun cause
it's a fun way to like you,
you'll let the kids get to ask questions
and you get to fuck around and come up
with things on the fly. And
uh, some, some guy said,
do you know any joke jokes or something
along those lines? Right. And I said,
I don't remember anyone. I go
out car. I remember this one,
two Jews walk into a bar, they buy
it. Like it's the end of the joke.
It's stupid. It's terrible. That joke.
A guy came up to me after the show and
said, that joke do you did about juices.
Very offensive.
I said,
what's offensive about it that
Jews are successful at business?
What's offensive that I use the
word Jew to Jews walk into a bar.
They went to a bar.
What parts offensive?
Or are you just looking to be
offended or you actually offended?
And he was flabbergasted.
He didn't know what to say because he
was a fucking 19 year old kid and he
thought he had his,
he was an awkward socially awkward person
and he thought this is my opportunity
to be right. And he just,
Oh, I'm offended. Like,
and there's all these kids
supporting each other. Yes,
you do have the right to be offended
and they're all fucking dumbest shit and
they don't have any life experience.
And they really,
they don't have a nuanced
view of the world yet.
And they're exercising this new muscle,
this new muscle of learning how
to call someone on their bullshit,
man on the patriarchy,
on the CIS,
cis gendered male, Hetero
normative bullshit that you
see every day. And they're,
they're like finding this,
this opportunity to express his rates.
And then eventually,
hopefully they'll settle in and hopefully
they'll sort of like, as time goes on,
they have more experience. They'll sort
of realize how ridiculous they were,
you know, when they were younger. But
it's like a natural inclination to like,
you know, you fucked up and you
know you've done wrong things.
So when you see it in other people call
it. So this one kid that said this to me,
I mean, that was the extent of our
conversation. I said, that's ridiculous.
Like what's not offensive? I go, I'm,
first of all, I don't tell I'm not racist.
And if I told a racist joke, he'd have
to be a really good, you know, and then,
and he goes, we should never tell racist
jokes. Like, oh, that's not true. I go,
if you, if you make me laugh
with a really funny racist joke,
I'm thankful because you made me laugh.
I don't think you think that everything
you say is a fucking sworn statement,
an affidavit that you're
getting giving in court.
I assume that when you're doing
the art of standup comedy,
you're going to say things you don't
really mean because they're funnier than
what you really mean.
And that's part of the art form.
Just like when you listen to a song,
you know,
Bob Marley didn't really
shoot the sheriff. Okay.
Probably didn't shoot anybody.
And it's like, it's, it's, it's part
of the art. It's making shit up.
And when you take that away because
people are going to be offended,
well then you remove almost every
movie that's ever been made.
You remove almost every book
that's ever been written.
You take away almost every standup
comedian set and you just get you,
you fucking
nerf the shit out of the
world and everybody is boring.
And that's not the answer.
It's not the answer.
I think this is a meniscus
or the reason why I, I,
I'm so happy to have done the Justine
sacco story in my book because I had so
much pushback and each
time I get pushed back,
I feel more and more happy that I did it.
Like [inaudible] gave a talk in knowledge.
One of the first talks I gave
was a knowledge in England. Um,
and somebody in the Q and a, somebody
said to me, somebody called out,
are you a racist? And I was like, cause I
defended just him and his like, you know,
so for 30 years I'm writing
about abuses of power.
And the first time I say we're the one's
abusing our power. So when he goes out,
are you a racist? And then, um, um,
I can try to fill it with,
he isn't that one person is our,
you're just dealing with really simple
thinking or that's just not a nuanced
objective.
Well thought out view of a human being.
What they're doing is looking for an
opportunity to call you out on something.
Yeah. Looking for an opportunity
to shame you. And that's what I,
the problem I have with all this social
justice warrior bullshit that's going on
in the world is it's Manufa,
it's manufacturing a lot of hate and
it's manuf manifesting itself in a very
angry way.
Where what,
what should be people that are pro
gay rights, Pro Chan's gender rights,
pro gay marriage pro,
a pro piece,
pro choice pro love
pro left wing ideology.
You know there's like do unto others
as you out have them do onto you.
This whole idea of like creating a more
peaceful world and the way they're going
to do it is by ruining everybody who
doesn't agree with them and shitting all
over them and insulting
them and not distinguishing
between what's actual social
justice and what's the kind of Cathartic
alternatives to social justice like
it's structured.
Have tested the deception
of Justine doesn't do any
good for anybody because she
wasn't even intending to be racist.
She was trying to make a liquid. She,
so it'd be like coach, he's going to be
like Trey Parker and Matt Stone. Right?
This isn't someone who's going after a
cop that shot a kid with a fake pistol or
anything. You know? This is, yeah,
exactly. And this is the real problem.
And the inability to distinguish between
the citizens discretion on the unsafest
transgression and what is creating as a
kind of surveillance society as kind of
stars. He where everybody's more fearful.
Everyone's scared to say things. Um,
the great thing about social media was
how it gave a voice to voiceless people.
And now people are fleeing social media
because they're realizing that the
smartest way to survive is to
go back to being voiceless. See,
I don't think that's true.
I don't think they are fleeing.
I think they're jumping out in droves.
I think some people are jumping off,
but I think that what you said,
the great thing about it is
it gives a voice to people.
It's also a terrible thing about
it. But I think what this is, is,
as I said before, is this is like a,
this adolescent stage of communication.
We're reaching this new
level of interaction where
we can interact with each
other instantaneously.
And that's just never,
by the way Tesla predicted this to Tesla
predicted smartphones a hundred years
ago.
And I,
I tweeted this quote today that somebody
sent my way absolutely fascinating.
Um, it was, uh, not just
a quote. It was a, um, a,
um,
a,
a piece that Tesla had
written and life in 1920s,
amazing where he predicted smartphones,
like literally described a modern smart
phone scroll down like w w were his
actual words like, no, no, it's
below that. You actually read it.
When wireless is perfectly applied,
the whole earth will be
converted into a huge brain,
which in fact it is all things being
particles have a real and rhythmic whole.
We shall be able to communicate
with one another instantly,
irrespective of distance.
Not only this,
but through television
and telephony like phones,
we shall be able to hear one another as
perfectly as though we were face to face
despite intervening distances of thousands
of miles and the instruments through
which we shall be able to do this.
We'll do this.
Do His will be, oh, do
his will, Huh? To do, hey.
Oh Dude will be amazingly simple
compared with our present telephone.
A man will be able to carry one in
his vest pocket. Holy Shit. Fuck.
That is unbelievable.
Fucking unbelievable. When
you read that paragraph,
you think TSF, Oma, God, you know
when we have that world for ourselves,
what an amazing we'll do.
It will beer.
The beer world of curiosity will be a
world of like understanding strangers of
nuance of contexts and said,
we have the world and we
completely throw away curiosity.
We throw away once we throw away
contexts and what we have instead is
condemnation. Well with dummies,
but not with everybody on TV.
Look,
I'm way more informed now than I ever
would have been if I had grown up in the
1960s like if I grown up in the 1960s
and I was a 47 year old man in 1967 I
wouldn't know Jack Shit. I would be an
ape. I mean that is true. But I do fair,
you know, my, I mean I
do fear that, you know,
maybe there's two types
of people in the world.
Those people who favor humans over
ideology and those people have favorite
ideology of humans. And Right now the
ID looks uh, a winning on central.
I don't think they are.
I think they did not. No,
I just think they're making more noise.
And I think that it's,
it's really a matter of who
those ideological people
are surrounding themselves
with.
I think they could be swayed into a more
understanding nature and we can decide
this is what somebody wrote about my
book, which I really great with. Uh,
something about,
you know,
we can decide who to listen
to that with Justine sacco.
The problem was that the bullies one la,
everyone is too scared to defend chesty
nobody defended just do that. No sub you,
you brave bastard. Look at you. Yeah.
Well a woman code handling
Lewis who writes for the
New Statesman wrote a review
of my public shaming book. She said that
she tries to defend Justine at night.
She wrote, I'm not sure. The joke was
intended to be racist and straight. Yeah,
I'd straight away she got this fury
of you're just a privilege bitch too.
So she said to her, to her shame, she shut
up. And that's what happened that night.
Like everybody shut up.
And it wasn't just on social media like
the mainstream media or got involved.
It was like, you know, and,
and that became like the
dominant narrative about
Justine sacco was actually,
it was kind of racist and I,
and anybody who tried to stick up
for her just got, got screamed down.
Well, I'm almost any defending
her in defending her.
I would say she's
probably a little racist,
which you can't really think like that.
It's okay to say that if
you're not a little racist.
But in cracking that joke and
saying something like that,
which is uncertain, unquestionably a
racist joke, just kidding. I'm white. Lol.
Right? Yeah. That's
fucking racist. You know,
think that stress for me,
it's like a bad Randy Newman saga
mean Randy Newman's sign short people.
So people got no reason to live. Like
we also said, I love La. You know,
is that tongue and cheek as well? Yeah.
This tongue and cheek because he sings,
look at those mountains, look at those
trees, look at that bum over there, man.
He's down on his knees.
You know,
it's a lot Randy Newman will do is that
he will acknowledge his own privilege
and then do a kind of grotesque, extreme
version of it. So comedy, he does that.
And so what people who does it and I
love La and I think that's exactly what
just in soccer was doing and that joke,
she was acknowledging her own
privilege and then mocking it,
but I didn't kind of
grotesque version of it.
And the only difference between Justin
and Randy Newman was there just in with
just wasn't any fucking good at it. Right.
That's a good point. I see your point.
Um,
it's,
it's hard to argue that it
couldn't possibly offend people,
but the idea that she knew
she was broadcasting it to
all those people that were
offended.
I think people just don't understand
what the fuck is going on when they say
things online that you know when the
New York Times extracted my book and if
fact check with the New York Times,
phoned up Justine and said to her like,
so before you got on the plane,
we used surprise that like he didn't get
any replies because while she was like,
you know all happened after she turned
off her phone and fell asleep and she
said I had 170 Twitter follows.
Nobody ever replies to it.
So she was usually like as a, she's
like yelling into an empty room flight.
So she probably got unreasonably
cocky because of that. Exactly, yeah.
She got on a plane and so she's
probably on Xanax and drinking,
which is what a lot of people do when
they get on planes. That's like a fucking,
this lady was explaining to
me that that's, she was like,
like she was bragging about it like,
you mean a glass of wine?
I was Xanax and I don't give a fuck about
anything. She was, it was hilarious.
She was just talking and I was like,
I wonder how many people take Xanax and
get on planes and apparently talking to
people that take Xanax, it's super
common, right? They get anxiety,
they're going to get a long
plane and also sleeping pills.
People take all asleep sleeping
pills and they get on planes
can Xanax. I was um, it's when order,
this was happening to me that when the
New York Times, you know, extra Kmart and,
and it was just so noisy.
It's sort of my noisiest stories
of when the book came out,
it was incredibly noisy. And I went
to the studio to do this video, uh,
like talking about my book and
the woman on before me, um,
was a doctor and she was doing a
video about her book and she said,
what's your book about?
And I said, public shaming,
which is all digital media piece in
the New York Times about Justine sacco.
And I said, I wrote it. And she said, Oh
wow, God, you must be so happy. I said,
actually I'm not happy. And she said,
why aren't you happy? And I said,
cause everyone is just so much noise.
And then he said to what
he want and I said a Xanax,
she got out, tighten, wrote
me a prescription for like
sixties adducts of which,
by the way, I've had one and a half. Uh,
I don't abuse Xanax. Breath off. Fuck.
It's easy to get medication and it's
very easy to get medication in United
States. If you go to the right
doctors, meaning go to any doctor.
Did you thought fuck, take it?
I took law. I took like a half.
It was like, that made me feel
a bit, I was no longer anxious.
I felt groggy and then I have to
weigh up what would I rather feel?
Groggy or anxious? Welcome to America.
That's our dilemma. Rocky. All anxious,
groggy, anxious, caffeinated or on
Adderall. But then I thought, God,
like when she said to me,
what are you warm?
Like all I could think of
to say was annex within.
Did I miss like an amazing opportunity?
Like I don't know anything I didn't know
anything about, you know, with the light,
much like way better things than sound.
Next I could have asked you like
really in a painkillers I guess,
but you'd have to like
say that you're on pain.
Xanaxes you could say you have anxiety
and they'll give you a medication. Yeah.
You know,
I know the guys do a w how do he went
to a doctor to get prescription because
uh,
he was a social justice warrior and a,
he said a bunch of incorrect things and
people attacked him and so he had to go
to the doctor. So he's freaked out.
Like he got a taste of his own medicine,
but that fucker I saw him
like six months later.
It's still shitting on people online.
Like you didn't,
didn't learn from the attack on him.
Like it's almost like they
get caught up in this,
they get addicted to this drama of
shitting on people of attacking people.
Yeah. It's weird. You know what?
Since I, I mean I don't do it anymore.
I do not pile it on anybody anymore.
Even people who deserve it.
I tend not to pile in on anymore.
I tell you what,
where I think it still comes from the
fact in my book, the suck for me anyway,
my book, the psychopath test, I,
I'm really critical of like labeling
coach and really I'm critical of like the
fact that the Dsm is 886 pages long and
has a mental disorder for everything.
And uh, and I, I most people I think
agree with me that that's kind of,
it's like easy to
agree with me about that.
But then on social media we do exactly
the same thing we labeled p and yet,
so the very same people who agree with
me about the, the kind of, you know,
what's wrong with labeling
culture in the world,
go home and do it
themselves and social media.
I've been really torn with this
very strange our dear lately. Um,
I had this conversation with my good
friend Duncan Trussell and we were, um,
we were talking about labels and um,
and self definition and the, the, the,
the sort of imprisonment of definition.
And I said, well, even words
like names for people. Like,
my name is Tom, you know, fuck head.
You know, whatever. And that has taught,
you know, you're a Whitmore and
as a Whitmore, you know, you're,
you're supposed to stand for something
in this world that I think, yeah,
we're Ronson's, goddammit,
you're on Rogan. Stephin up. Boy.
I think these ideas of,
of like having a name,
like a label. Like you're, you're Coca
Cola, you know, you're Jamie Vernon.
You know, there's this, I think
having, instead of just being,
you like having names even dames
themselves, like, and he'd say, Oh,
well you know what to expect. It's
that fucking John Ronson guy. You know,
like all of a sudden you
can be boxed in and defined.
You're not just a human being who is
sort of like a existing with these other
human beings. You are a labeled human
being and that label can be great.
You know, you can be the Dalai
Lama or that label can be shit.
You could be Donald Trump, you
know, and you're, you right now,
Donald Trump has an easy pylon.
Everybody will jump on him.
He said a bunch of racist things about
Mexicans and much dumb shit during his
speech announcing he's
going to be president.
He's an easy pylon and he's also a guy
that sort of embraces self definition.
He embraces his label so much so that he
puts his label on the top of a building.
Trump towers.
This is the,
the Trump casino on the Trump this and
like it's a part of the definition I
think any sort of definition like
that. Like officer, professor,
you know, doctor, you know,
how about people that want,
like Cosby was making people call him a
doctor when he got an honorary doctorate.
You know, I guess maybe,
you know, secretly it was a,
a big joke for him cause he was drugging
people, you know, allegedly. Yeah.
New News right now it's came out,
he admitted to 2005 and court,
I'll show you the little article. Oh
well this just, oh, just happened.
All my goodness.
He it in a 2005 deposition that he
obtained quite ludes a sedative with the
intent of giving them to women he wanted
to have sex with according to records
obtained by the Associated
Press on Monday,
the admission was contained in records
that were unsealed after the AP went to
court to compel the release.
Cosby's attorneys had repeatedly
sought to keep the record sealed,
arguing that they would be
embarrassing. This was, um,
a case that Cosby I'm
paid a woman off and then,
uh,
because he had paid off
part of the deal.
Uh,
part of the arrangement was that the
records are to be sealed. So they, uh,
went to court and wow, he's fucked
now. It, we were like three and a half.
Another thing I was reading this
big, I said, God, what a monster.
What's the statute of limitations? And all
of their staff can vary. Any questions?
I think I can be, well, 2005, I can't
imagine the statue of limitations is,
well, if that's 2005, that's
when he admitted it. But
when was the actual instance?
That's monster shit. That's
really, that's dehumanizing shit.
I think we can go,
that's a long conversation.
It's sort of semi-related the definition
of bill Cosby because bill Cosby is,
is sort of iconic individual and bill
Cosby has a celebrity and because of that
he was worshiped and
treated like a celebrity.
And I think because of that worship,
he sort of had an expectation
of worship and also an egg.
This is total armchair psychology from
a dude who went to college for three
years and barely paid
attention. But the, I think the,
the expectation of that and the years
and years of that much like being a
spoiled child and leads you to be a person
who expects that from people and can
even justify horrific behavior because
you actually do think that you're better
than someone the same way. Royalty
does the same way, you know,
people who have not grown up their lines,
that behavior and growth kind of
reason. And a lot of ways, I mean,
I think there's,
I think it's related in a
way to the idea of labeling,
labeling and you know, just, you
know, that's not a human being.
That's a police officer,
officer Johnson, you know, uh,
you refer to the judge as
your honor. You know, you, you
can't go, hey man, you know,
I know you're reading off a book,
but don't lock me in a fucking cage cause
I had a joint order in the court who
we'll refer to him as your honor.
You know what I mean? Like that,
that all that stuff,
they'll fucking,
when they used to wear a crazy wigs
and outfits, what are they doing? Well,
they're separating themselves.
They're differentiating themselves
and their labeling though they're,
they're putting themselves in a very
distinctive position, lay. And it's,
it's really one of the,
it's one of the worst things
that's happening in this
country at the moment. Uh,
that I in, in, in the psychopath test,
I writes about how these kids as young
as one and two are getting labeled
bipolar because everyone is so in love
with the checklists that a kid goes to
see a psychiatrist with a temper tantrum
and [inaudible] goes higher and the
bipolar check list.
So if it then given antipsychotic
medication at the age of light,
literally one and two, that's how much
labeling culture is out of control.
You don't, I said Dude, and
it's the question I love
asking most is why, you know,
cause I opens doors,
you know why you have to go some of us.
But with labeling culture, including labor
and culture on social media, it's lie,
it closes doors,
labels closed us questions,
open doors where they certainly
define in like a very concrete way.
This is what I felt,
you know,
I felt most a step lightly with the
whole Rachel dollar shower thing because
when I heard that story I just thought
that is so mysterious and complicated and
nuanced and you know,
maybe she's,
maybe she's mentally ill or maybe
she's not. Whatever's going on here.
This is like really fucking mysterious
and interesting and I like a thousand
questions.
And so I went on Twitter expecting that
that would be Twitter's response to,
they'd have like a thousand questions,
but no,
people were either like ridiculing her
or attacking her like yelling black face
or whatever. But there's plenty
of people supporting her,
her position as being trans racial. Those
are my favorite, right? Those people,
rod durable.
Right.
But I just thought fucking hell,
I can't,
you know what I thought,
I thought I'd been a journalist for 30
years and I'm sick and I don't know where
to go with us,
but I thought I'm really sick of like
damaged people being other people's play
things,
either ideological placings or play
things for mockery or whatever.
And obviously there's nothing wrong
with comedy and satire and mockery. I,
and that's fine, but nonetheless,
so God [inaudible]. But nonetheless,
I'm just sort of sick
of, of cruelty. Yeah.
Making other human beings are
play things instead of, you know,
for whatever reasons, instead
of like curiosity. Well, if
it was as simple as play,
uh, play things like, just,
just straight up mockery,
I would expect that you would get some
clever humor out of it. But it's hate.
There's a lot of anger and hate and this
whole public shaming thing sort of goes
along with that.
I mean,
there's some people that I follow that I
don't agree with. And a w unfortunately,
I agree with their position on a
lot of things like a marriage, like,
you know, uh, equality for all.
Like there's so many different things
that I agree with like extreme left wing
people on that.
It's really problematic because when
some of them adopt this sort of social
warrior public shaming stance,
I'm so torn because on one
side I want to go after them.
[inaudible] another side.
I agree with almost all of their positions
on equality for women and equality
for gay people and across,
I mean there's so many of the positions
that I have the exact same stance on,
but I don't have this stance
on public shaming or if I do,
my stance is public humor.
You know, my, my stance,
whether Chris Christie says he's gonna
lock up everyone who smokes marijuana,
you know, oh, because marijuana is
so dangerous. I'm like, Jesus Christ.
Do you have a fucking
mirror in your house?
You're morbidly obese and you're telling
people that they can't have a substance
that has never killed a single person
ever over being overweight is one of the
major causes of premature death
in the United States of America.
But how having a heart attack is one
of the major causes and having a heart
attack is almost directly related
in most people to being overweight.
I mean it's a huge issue and this fucking
Slob is on television telling people
that he's going to stop marijuana because
it's dangerous and the only stuff and
hot dogs in its fat face like to me a
guy like that has to be mocked because
it's,
it's there and that's my job.
Just like the fucking crocodile sees the
wounded antelope and it gets too close
to the waterhole, it can't
help it. It's got a snap ad.
If I'm a comic and you say something
stupid like that and you are just as
blatantly obvious target,
like that is a dangerous person in my,
in my opinion, because he's a person
who could dictate policy. Well,
he's a person who can make laws and he's
a person that literally can lock people
up in jail. He can get, he can get
people's freedom taken away. Yeah.
He had punching up and nipping funny
and there's nothing, you know, I,
I'd be a real dope if I was going to
stop being against things like that.
I guess,
you know,
what my books against
is the disproportionate
punishment of people who don't
deserve it. And that's the bullying. Yeah.
It's piling on. I mean, it, it, it's,
it's also having a lack of,
there's a lack of perspective that comes
with a lot of these pile on bullying.
Things like the, um, the what, what's the
woman's name again? Soco. Justin. Yeah.
Rachel Dolezal thing. First of all, um,
she handled herself very well on Matt
Lauer. Yeah. I should say, by the way,
that may sort of saying all do that
stuff on Twitter was raw at the beginning
before she'd said anything.
I was like to say, look,
we don't know anything about this
woman. You know, we don't know anything.
Like everyone's jumping to conclusions,
nobody knows anything.
And I was just like,
screamed at for that.
And she had some other issues though
that were exposed as time went on.
And one of them is, she's a
plagiarist. Oh yeah, yeah.
She plagiarized some art and she was
selling some art that she clearly
plagiarized and she's just deceptive.
She lied about her background.
She said she was born in a teepee.
Like she's just not a truthful person.
And sometimes when people don't
enjoy their life, um, you know, I've,
I've met a lot of kids when
I was young that, you know,
came from really fucked up backgrounds
and those are the ones that told like the
really big lies.
And I think that a lot of those lives
were because they didn't like their
reality, you know, and that's, they
didn't, they didn't ask to be born that,
you know, there's a mystery, right.
With people like that you liked.
So what happened? Why do you
feel that way? What's going on?
Whereas effectual delish I like the
minute this breaks some social media.
If it wouldn't just like, you know,
fucking racist, shut the fuck up.
There's no questions.
It's black.
You would get really angry because she's
appropriating a disenfranchise segment
of society has already been stolen from,
from white by white people. You know,
and I had people tweeting me to
say, you know, you were white man.
This isn't your story. Get
ancillaries, isn't it? You don't have,
you're not allowed to have an opinion
because you weren't born with the right
amount of melanin in your skin.
So mind
is not working right.
Would they said this is your story.
You can't come until this. This is cause
this isn't your story. That's bullshit.
When I felt it kind of
was my story because I've,
for 30 years I've been
writing about trouble people
and I've come to conclusions
about the way you should regard of the
people at the human beings with sort of
interest in curiosity and
compassion, not cold, hard judgment.
So that's where I came
from and that story.
It's also that the saying that it's not,
you're not allowed,
I have an opinion or it's not your story.
That is you.
What you're trying to do is you're trying
to silence anybody that doesn't agree
with you.
Everyone that is a human being that
witnesses a story you witnessed,
some public thing was taking place.
You are absolutely allowed your opinion
and if you're not going to allow people
to speak up about things and
have opinions about things,
whether these opinions are
informed or uninformed,
that's all going to be
sorted out in the wash.
But it to say it's not your position
to talk well then your public
like silence people and you
know exactly what that is.
The opposite of of course is is democracy.
And when I was reading people,
I went off social media after all of that
cause there was so much screaming and
I was reading people basically saying,
okay,
let's go to John Ronson into saying
something outrageous and then we can get
him. Is that what they said?
Yeah. I always feel like,
you know why they'd say that?
It's because, uh, the,
the young have decided for some
misdefined reason to create an incredibly
stressful world for themselves.
I don't think they realize what they are,
it's what they're
doing. Um, but the, the Rachel
dolls all thing was, uh,
to me it was a perfect example of
how ludicrous human beings are,
how ridiculous our society is
and how this woman is. Like,
first of all,
the NAACP was founded by white people
as something a lot of people don't know.
And Black folks weren't even allowed to
hold office until the 1970 [inaudible]
while at the cotton club.
And a lot of ways, well,
it was actually founded by New
York City intellectuals, I believe.
I hope I'm not doing this wrong,
that, um, they, they really, uh,
it was in response to all the lynchings
and, you know, they were like,
they were just, they were
compassionate, intelligent, uh,
progressive people that we're trying
to figure out a way past this horrible
situation that the world,
it found himself in post slavery where
there was all this resentment and there
was, there was lynched lynchings and
just the chaos that is the south.
And you know,
I think we're still dealing with the
reverberation of the repercussions and the
reverberations of it right now with this
confederate flag debate that's going on
all throughout America now.
It's like America's just sort of kind
of waking up to the fact that we'll fuck
man, a hundred or so years ago
you were allowed to own people,
you know, and the people that wanted
to be able to own people had a flag
and these people put that flag on a car
and drove it around on TV and we didn't
think about it. Yeah. You know,
and now we're thinking about it and
you know the rec code, by the way,
I was always disappointed when the chooks,
if house it was on TV that
because of the flag. No,
just cause it wasn't as good as wonder
woman. But this is a cut attention.
What about Daisy Duke? Well wonder
what, it was pretty fucking hot too.
I spent a lot of time with
the Ku Klux Klan. You know,
from, from my book there, my,
I discovered this,
I'm politically correct faction
of the Ku Klux Arkansas.
Yes.
Run by a guy called Tom Rob who decided
that the Klan had a really bad image.
Ah, he was going to do
something about it recently.
Notice it's like the mid nineties.
I wrote about it in my book then
why is he back in the news? No,
there's another group,
another factor of the Ku Klux Klan
that was allowing black people and they
wanted to allow black people in.
Oh really?
Where that is the kind of thing
that Tom would have done. In fact,
Tom was accused by other white
supremacists of kissing a black baby. Um,
I, and you have to kind of deny it. You
got to hit to issue a denial black baby.
But I went to, I went to Tom's
house and he directed, so we'd band,
I went to this big annual convention and
he banned like the robes and the hoods.
They were allowed to wear robes one day.
Uh,
and they were loud and they were
allowed to burn a cross one day.
Yeah.
And it was the day that I turned up and
they were all stunned to grab this giant
cross.
It's lying on the ground.
And they couldn't remember
because they were also rusty.
They couldn't remember whether to soak
it and then raise it or raise it and then
soak it. Oh, that's hilarious.
Those starting ground.
And then Tom comes over
and they go, Tom, we cut.
Do we soak it and then raise it or
raise it and then soak it. And Tom Goes,
you soca and then raise it. How the, how
the hell are you going to lie? So kind.
I don't say, Hey Carrie. I know.
Then Tom looks at me as if to say,
I'm so sorry that my members
are such idiots. Like Tom
preferred me to the clown.
Oh my God, that's a door. And then he,
and then they had this kid in his garden.
Um,
and they're all doing this kind of
personality skills, workshops. Like,
like they were filling
out these multiple choice,
like which strengths and
weaknesses most apply to you. Um,
I always remember like
one of the strengths, the
weaknesses was mixes easily,
which normally would be like a strength.
But if you're the clan it's been,
it's gotta be weakness.
And then another one was warrior.
And what are the classmen was like going,
well,
I don't consider being a
warrior to be a weakness.
And then like the person
doing the test was like,
why is she being a
worrier can be a weakness.
And he thought it was warrior and
it was worrying. Oh God. Yeah.
Worrier. Are you a
worrier? Englishes English.
Yeah. I was an Englishman. I'm
a worrier. Oh, I see. Yeah.
Well I could see someone
saying I'm a worrier,
but I couldn't see it as a question.
Are you a worrier? I would see,
think the question would be a little bit
more straight forward like do you worry
a lot?
I've got,
I've got to say to kind of genetic most
poor choice question and answer thing.
Worry. I would be like an odd word to
have had that. Are you a warrior? Yes sir.
I am. I'm a warrior for
the race, but I'm not.
I'm a warrior
now.
What is the reason why they
burn the cross? It's a cross.
They couldn't across the lighting,
not a cross burning.
It goes back to glass
half full sort of a thing.
I think it goes back to the Scottish,
I believe it's all to do with like,
I can't remember if they told me, you
know what it's like being a journalist.
Like you know everything.
For sure it's hard,
but then you move onto the next story.
You write your, sorry, forget it. Oh,
I've got a terrible memory. Anyway, I've
lost it. It's like being a podcast or two.
We've talked about things.
We've done 667 episodes now so
we can not to six, six, seven,
six,
six Duncan Trussell
fake evil fakey well he's a great guy,
but he could play evil.
One time I was, uh, I went on a road
trip with the Klan from Harrison,
Arkansas to St Paul.
Long journey, like 17 hours. I was in a
car for 17 hours with the Klan. Whoa. I,
at one point Tom turned to me the leader
and he said, can I ask you a question?
And I said, well, and he said,
do you think I'm weird? Wow.
Yeah.
And I was like,
I think you're in a transitional
phase between where to not wear it.
Oh, that's interesting. So you were
playing like psychological, uh,
when I was in the car with game lamb,
but saying there isn't a transitionary
period. Like what did you mean by that?
Well, cause he was trying to, you know,
trying to do an image maker virtue
and be more politically correct.
It didn't really turn out in,
did he feel that black
people were inferior to white
people to be really clearly
feel that?
Well,
he would probably call himself
like a white sat protest,
but he wasn't actually,
I'm an,
I've met white separatists
like Randy Weaver and Fr.
The third nicer people than
Tom was a Randy Weaver who's
a Ruby Ridge guy. Right.
He's wiped separatist.
I'm really gone.
I got on well with the weaver
has gotten really why Rachel,
his daughter in that story
is kind of a fucked up story.
Right?
Like he was a,
they had a house alone in the woods and
they were killed by snipers. Right. Yeah.
This is a really bad story.
So they were,
this is the first story I ever did where
I feel like I kind of twisted it rounds
that the people who would normally
be the villains were the good guys,
the people that normally be the good guys.
Were the villains
satisfied good about that.
So basically they were family of light,
you know,
they believe in Bohemian Grove
and Bilderberg and I went,
I am tried to infiltrate,
build a book one time by the way,
and got chased away by their hedgemon.
I don't if this time to tell that
story as a planet. Okay. So, uh,
so they moved to this cabin up in the
words on top of the mountain and Idaho,
Ruby Creek, Idaho and Randy, uh,
would hang out at the local
area nations with the family.
That was his big undoing was that he,
we would take the family up to area
nations who were just, you know,
a fucking nuts,
like violent skin,
had nuts and Randy would take his family
up there for like picnics and away days
and so on. So Arian nations, like
pretty much every white supremacist,
you know, group in America
was heavily infiltrated by,
by undercover officers.
And they saw a Randy and saw his family
and could tell that Randy was less crazy
than the other people there.
So they approached Randy and said,
you want to become an undercover
informant? And Randy said, no.
So then Mandy thought that was that.
But then they sent a guy to ask
Randy to saw off a shotgun. So He's,
so he said,
okay fine.
So we sawed off shotgun
slightly below the legal limit,
like the guy pointed at him.
It's a no, so it off there.
So we sorted off there and then
they said, ah, we've got you. Um,
this was an undercover cop.
You've now committed to firearms offense.
You will go to jail in less.
You become an undercover informant for us.
And Randy being a,
being a Twat said no fuck off.
And he kind of embarrassed the
feds in front of his wife. He said,
look at those two guys over there.
Guess what they just asked me to do?
And so Randy was like an idiot.
And then he,
he locks himself up in the cabin
with his wife and kids and dog.
Um, and then, and so they
surrounded the cabin,
the ATF. And this went
on for like a year, uh,
that they set up cameras in the trees
and surrounded Roundy's cabinet.
And one day the, um, the,
the ATF people got too close to the cabin
and disturb the dog and the dog starts
barking and the dog chases
the agents down the hill.
And Randy's little boy who was,
who was like 12 years old or something.
Sammy chased the dog down the
hill with a gun because Randy,
like an idiot had armed his kids.
And uh,
so they all run down to the bottom of
the hill and agents jumps out and shoots
the dog, kills the dog. Sammy
says, you killed my dog,
you son of a bitch and
start shooting wildly.
And the agent shoots Sammy in his arm
and basically shoot his arm nearly off.
And somebody yells, Dad, I'm coming home
dad. And starts running up the hill.
And the ATF agent just shoots summary in
the back cause he's running up the hill
just instead, sort of volley of
gunfire. So, so some is now dead.
This story doesn't get any better,
I should tell you, Sam is now dead.
Rundy get some,
these body puts them in the shed.
And then the next day, oh, um,
one of Randy's friends is there and
there's a shootout and one of the agents I
called bill and gets killed tools
and I've got to dead people.
You've got a dead agent and
you've got Sammy Dad. Um,
the jewelry's always been asked as to
whether the agent was killed by Randy's
friend or by friendly fire.
Um, so anyway, the next day,
Randy goes outside and an FBI
sniper called Alon Harriet.
She shoots Randy in the shoulder.
So Randy runs back in and Vicki Randy's
wife was standing in the doorway holding
a baby and a sniper shoots Vicki
through the head and kills a,
and they'd pull Vicky's
body into the cabin. And,
and a siege starts like a
16 day siege or something.
And art that I had the road
blocked down at the bottom.
That's kind of where the
militia movement started,
like all these local militia people or
form at the bottom of the roadblock and
for days, and then discover that
Vicky's dad. And, and I mean,
I've seen some amateur footage
and it's tiered, so sad. And,
and I became really good
friends with Rachel, who's
Randy's younger daughter, uh,
who was in the cabin full of
that time. And I did. In the end,
the government admitted responsibility
and paid each around these daughters a
million dollars each and
they killed Randy. Uh, no,
Randy still alive. Rezzy now?
Yeah.
Randy now goes to gun shows where you can
have your photograph taken with Randy.
We for $4. God. Yeah. And how much? $5.
He sells himself. Quite short
bargain. Yeah. A historical figure.
So that's, so one of the people
who visited Randy's cabin.
I've visited Randy's cabin with Rachel
and another person who visited Randy's
cabin was Timothy Mcveigh.
Um,
shortly before blowing up the
Murrah building in Oklahoma City.
Have you ever seen the conspiracy
theories on that? About yeah,
I visited della him city. The
place which you know about, right.
The place where you know, I, you know,
I know I've got a kind of reputation for
being a, a debunker of conspiracies and,
and the reputation has cut
a warranted in most cases,
but I've got to say of all the things I,
I investigated when I was doing a
lot of stuff about conspiracies.
The one where I thought this
is a bit fucking fishy was,
was Oklahoma City.
Yeah.
Oh, it's, it's most certainly fishery.
What's most certainly fishy
is the efficacy of that bomb.
The bomb that they used,
a fertilizer bomb that blew half there
building apart when you talked to bomb
experts, they go that is
like really, really unlikely.
And they said that the amount of damage
that a bomb like that that's made out of
fertilizer can do is nothing in
comparison to what that building was like.
And also that that building,
um,
looked like it had been blown out.
Not it had been blown in but blown out,
meaning that there was bombs
planted inside the building.
And then there was all these news reports
as another one of Alex Jones is a,
uh,
stories.
There was all these news reports that
he played these clips of where they were
talking about FBI agents for moving bombs,
unexploded bombs from the building,
and that there were more than one
bomb. And then they had this, you know,
this narrative that they blamed it on
Timothy Mcveigh and what was the other
guy's name? Terry Nichols.
Terry Nichols. Yeah. And um,
that it was this fertilizer
bomb. And remember there's
like, oh, there's all this,
they were looking for a guy from
Iraq and there was all this,
like the different stuff that
was going on in the news,
like right after it was over.
But then they had settled on the story
that he had done it and they had done it
all with this fertilizer bomb. But, um,
it's, it's, it's a weird one because,
I mean,
I don't have an answer and I don't even
have a theory like who could have done
it or how it was done or what
would have been done. I mean, look,
all we know is someone blew up
that fucking building. I mean,
if it was just him and Terry Nichols,
it was just Timothy Mcveigh
and Terry Nichols. Um,
that to me is no more crazy than it was
a bunch of other people that planted
bombs inside the building. It's all
a heinous act of horror and murder.
Yeah.
The way it,
the way it thing that we discovered
tonight when I was doing the Oklahoma's
story was it's best called Ella him city.
If you have you heard of this
place? So I visited Alahan city, uh,
the old Dale.
This is like this kind of white separatist
stroke supremacist compound and the
Arkansas or Oklahoma board as
an in the Ozarks spooky spot.
Yeah. I turned up in the audit, the
river dance for me. Oh, Jesus. Yeah.
I'd just been chased through Portugal by
the Bilderberg group and I bonded with
them over that. Like I tell
him, I told him, I don't know,
I just been chased by bill.
Yeah. Everyone, all of these,
all of that crowd back there knows you've
got Bilderberg. Um, and I said, yeah,
I've just been chased by the
Bilderberg group, which I was, I, um,
it in my book then when I was trying
to infiltrate secret societies,
I went to Portugal with Jim
Tucker. Um, the, he ran,
he worked for this magazine
called the spotlight,
which was run by this kind
of white separatist group
called the liberty lobby in
Washington DC.
Basically everybody kept telling me about
this group called the Bilderberg group
that no one had heard of back then.
Only only real niche aficionados
that her to build a poke back then.
Um, and, uh, much in the
same way that I kind of law.
I feel like I partly launched Alex Jones,
his career.
I also feel like partly gave the world
build a bird because I was the first lap
mainstream writer to write about it
because everyone was saying that there's
this group called the Bilderberg group
and they secretly rule the world from
inside a secret room. Uh, and I
said, if you ask big Jim Tucker,
he'll tell you more. So, so
I phoned up Jim Tucker, uh,
and he said, yeah, it's true.
They always meet once a year to five
star hotel with golfing facilities.
And that's where they all the world. And
he said, you've caught me at a good time.
I want to say look like
something out of like sub spade.
I had an office of 50 should
blind to the word trill bay,
and he smoked like 80 a day. Uh,
he said that he had emphysema,
which made him sound even more like
seminar. He died a couple of years ago,
but he lusted a fuck of lot longer
than I had to put money on him. And I,
I met him in March and I
thought he'd be dead by May,
but actually lasted about another 10
years. Wow. Yeah. He only dad recently,
like a couple of years ago and this was
[inaudible] 96 so Tim said, uh, he said,
yeah,
I've discovered where they've got to meet.
Like my secret sauce has told me that
there'd be to get the seaside Park Hotel
at golfing resorted Sidra Portugal
and I'm going to fly over there.
I apologize in my, send
me American accent. Uh,
I'm doing here is I got to fly over there
and climbed up the drain pipes and get
in and confronting red handed. Gogebic
they're covert wickedness. So I said,
can I come? And he said, okay, as long
as you to use a term covert wicked.
I might be slightly exaggerate,
he might put an English,
but basically I, I'm pretty sure he
said he was going to cloud the Trophon,
wickedness, white supremacy.
That's all they talk. Yeah.
So we flew the best,
so be a,
Jim Tucker flew to Portugal
and scouted around the,
the Park Hotel. And we decided
that our cover story would be like,
he'd be like a sales,
we'd be salesman,
but we didn't look at anything
that fucking sales when I
was like early thirties,
you know, skinny little Jewish guy. And
he was like this big southern gentleman.
So we looked like really fucking
good shuffle. Yeah. Like gay couple.
I could it be like as toy boy, uh,
I like, we realize scouting a lot,
try to talk to waitresses and stuff.
This was the day before the Bilderberg
group was reportedly go to arrive at this
hotel.
And then we left and we started getting,
I looked in my rear view mirror
and it was a car following me and,
and a, and a chase ensued, um,
like through the streets. I mean,
I say a chase, I was going 30 miles an
hour, so, so we say, but I keep thinking,
I kept thinking, fuck, if I
speed up, he's going to speed up.
It's gonna be like a fucking chase.
So it was very obvious. It was fine.
He wasn't trying to be sneaky. No. Well,
I stopped the car and he
stopped his car like behind me.
So I, I thought I've got
to say something to him.
So I went over to the car and I like
knocked on the window and there's a guy in
dark glasses in the car looking straight
ahead and I'm knocking on the window
and he refuses to look at me.
Like obviously his orders were
to follow but don't engage.
Like I'm suddenly in a
world where I am lie big,
followed by somebody whose orders
are to follow and not engage.
So I freak the fuck out.
So I get back in the car and I phone
up first I filled up my wife and I say,
I'm being followed by the Bilderberg
group. I am fucking terrified.
And my wife goes, oh, you're loving it.
And I'm like, oh no. And
then I found it, oh gosh.
Embassy and I brought at the
British embassy and I said,
I'm being followed by
the Bilderberg group. Um,
and then the one for the British
embassy goes and then she cold.
And I'm like, I just want you
to take a shot. I then she says,
what do you do? They know, you know, did
they know your hair? I mean, what are you,
what are you doing here?
And I said,
I am essentially a humorous
journalist out of my depth.
Can you foam what I also said to her,
to my shame,
I didn't put this in my book or I write
about all of this in my book. Then, um,
what I didn't say, what I didn't put it
in my book was that I also said to her,
I said, I'm a humorous to enlist, started
my depth. I'm a bit like Louis Theroux.
And she's like, oh, like she's heard of
him and not me. And I'm like, I don't.
I'm like,
yeah,
but actually Louis often
cites me as an inspiration.
I swear to God,
this is like my last day on earth.
I'm about to be killed by the Bilderberg
group telling the press officer for the
British Embassy in Portugal that
Louis actually speaks highly of me.
So then I, then she says,
she says this, she said,
this is the, this is like the most
startling thing that happened that day.
She said, well, the good news is
if you know you're being followed,
they're probably just trying to
intimidate you, intimidate you,
and the dangerous ones would be
those you don't know a following you.
And I'm thinking first,
how the fuck does the press officer at
the British embassy, no, this and hey,
what if these people
are the dangerous ones?
And I just happened to be like
naturally good at spotting them.
Like I'm an anxious person. I, I will
spot, like I suffer from anxiety.
Like I will spot if somebody is
following me. Right? Yeah. So anyway,
so then she did not go
back to my hotel and uh,
the woman for the British embassy phones
be back and says that she's spoken to
the Bilderberg group and they've said
that nobody is following me. Yeah.
So I'm like, he's behind the tree.
Like I'm by the pool, I'm going,
he's standing behind the tree and
Chicos will not just sit tight.
I'm sure it's going to,
I'm sure it's going to go away.
So I went down to the beach, Jim Tucker
throughout all of this. By the way,
he's loving it.
He's loving every fucking second of this.
It's his dream come true. I'm
sure. Yeah. I go down to the bit,
I'm petrified.
I want to like abandon the story,
like drive back to England from Portugal
because I'm afraid I'm going to get
like stopped at immigration. Uh,
Yay in pretty much you can get in.
Get the ferry from,
from Paris. Uh, so, uh,
so I think it's, it's like a two
day drive, but fuck it. Right.
So then I had a camera man with me,
David Barker,
cause I was filming some of
this through a documentary.
He convinced me to like stick it out.
Uh, so I went to the beach and then I,
and then I came back to the
hotel and I suppose God,
there's these two men in dark glasses
sitting in the lobby of the hotel.
And as soon as I walk in, they both
grab brochures and start reading them.
And I'm like, fuck. So I go
up to Jim Tucker and I said,
there's these two men in the lobby
and reading brochures in the morning
pretending to read broaches uh, Jim
says, how do you, how do you know?
And I said,
you can tell by their demeanor.
And then later when Jim wrote all of
this up for his conspiracy website,
he like transcribe this conversation.
And he said, I said to Rod, said,
how could you tell I'm not send replied,
you could tell them by this bell.
And I'm glad I didn't say smell.
I said to me though,
what does the Bilderberg or
smell like? Yeah, like power.
So the hedgemon spelled
like badly paid power.
So, uh, anyway, that was
basically it. But, uh,
the next day we went back to the hotel
and instead at the bottom and watched all
of these people driving up the
drive. Um, Henry Kissinger,
David Rockefeller like, yeah, and they
all really did turn up Vernon Jordan,
who was Bill Clinton's lie man
behind, you know, like, like,
like Bill Clinton's like, you
know, man in the background,
lots of people in the background.
Is there an official explanation for
the Bilderberg group? Yeah, well,
much later on,
like after all this happened,
I managed to interview three
members of the Bilderberg group,
including the secretary general,
uh,
and including one of their
founding fathers who,
so who was this British politician
who's still alive, called Denis Healey,
who was a big labour politician
in the 1970s and he said,
and I believe them, that Bilderberg was
set up after the Second World War. Um,
because there was this big move against
ideological politicians like post Hitler
and I were doing any more hit LED's.
So let's cut to create this sort of
globalist one world new world order.
I mean, you know, the, the phrase
new world order I think is true.
I think they were trying to create like
a one world government or business would
be more important than politics because
business people are more trustworthy
than ideological politicians.
I think that that was their,
that was their thesis back then.
So it was kind of a centrist,
almost kind of liberal in a, in a
way. Um, if you buy that Jon Ronson,
I've got a bridge to you in Portugal when
I think that that was where they came
from, but of course what
they didn't account for or
maybe did account for it and
didn't give a shit was the CEOs
would be just as fucking evil and uh,
and, and malicious and ideological
in their own way as politicians.
And so that's why build a book
became this kind of more nefarious,
presumably became slightly more nefarious
thing. Yeah. I think if the zone,
if there's ever going to be one
antidote for power is it's information.
It's being able to expose all the
dealings and secret organizations like the
Bilderberg group or to a lesser extent,
the Bohemian Grove type folks.
Like I think only thing that sort
of mitigates that and diminishes that is
everyone knowing about that and knowing
more people,
excuse me.
No more people know about the
bill burgs now than ever before.
The Bilderberg group is like something
that will, people will, they'll, they'll,
they'll say it, they don't really
know a lot. Like I'll say it,
I don't know much about it.
I know that really important.
Rich people meet and they discuss things
and every single person has ever been
president has met.
Yeah,
I set that actually to the secretary
general of the Bilderberg group when I
interviewed him Skakel Martin
Taylor, I said to, you know,
you've got so many like up and coming
politicians who ended up being like
president or prime minister.
And he said thank you.
Lucky took that as a
compliment. I like, you know,
we're good at star spotting the next. And
Denis Healey said to me, look, the idea,
yeah, starts pissing. And
Dennis Haley said to me,
the idea is to get these
rising politicians and
introduce them to the heads of
business and hopefully influence them to
be more sensible and more globalist and
less less nationalist, I
think horror them out. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. I mean it's a network. I
mean, no question. No question. You know,
all these places exist for a reason.
I take a bit of credit.
I think he might book them was the first
time Bilderberg like was ever discussed
in kind of mainstream, the mainstream
world. And then shortly after me,
this journalist called
Charlie's scout and cable long,
here's another sort of mainstream
writer for the Guardian.
And he goes every year to build a Burg
now and partly result of hearing the
parties may suddenly build a book is
discussed in the mainstream world.
But when I went to build a burger now,
like loads of people like turn up
to protest Bilderberg and so on,
and they've even got a bit
of a website now, I think.
And they certainly admit existing
now and it didn't use to,
they kind of have to write
inflammation thing. Yeah.
So it's partly to do with with them and
partly to Charlie Skelton, your book,
them. Uh, you know, I'm,
I'm very fascinated by extremists
and, uh, I'm very fascinated by,
uh,
I'm very fascinated by the spectrum of
human thinking and behavior and that
we're all kind of terrified of people
that are on the far end in one way or
another.
We're terrified of like extreme lefties
or terrified of extreme righties,
you know. Did you, when did you,
was anything like really revealing or
unusual about that journey of trying to
write that in your own mind?
Did you try to like,
one of the things I try to do when
I watch like isis videos or a watch,
like a radical fundamentalist
Islamic guys talk,
I try to imagine myself agreeing with
them and being one of them and being happy
to be one of them that like, you
know, like there's, there's some,
there's some appeal and some draw to being
extremely confident about what you're
saying. Even if what you're
saying is absolutely ridiculous,
like stoning people for homosexuality
and you see all of that happening on
social media, which I write
about in the new book. He had a,
you see this cut of joy in approval.
Mutual approval mean that's what I
think is a problem with Twitter is it's,
it's become like a sort of mutual
approve or machine that we surround us as
people feel the same way we
do and we approve each other.
And that's such a great feeling if
everybody gets in the way and says,
I don't agree with,
with what you're doing here,
you feel ferociously angry about
that when he screamed them out.
And Yeah.
So I think this kind of mutual approval
that goes on in both on social media and
also an extremist groups,
don't you think that people say things?
A lot of the things they say, they say
knowing that people are going to approve.
So they tailor these things in a way that
like they lick their finger and put it
up in the air and they catch the wind.
Like, Ooh, the wind's going this way.
I'm going to say something that puts
me on the moral high ground. Yeah.
I'm gonna get a lot of retweets.
Yeah. Uh, yeah. And it's, it's, it's,
I think it's kind of damaging. I mean,
you know, like you said before, you know,
I come from a social justice world,
so I believe in all the things that they
believe in. I believe in gay marriage.
I believe in all of those things,
but at the same time I feel kind of
uncomfortable when I feel like there's a
kind of ferocious conformity
going that you have to,
you have to say it like every
time somebody dies you have to,
I remember when Robin Williams died, like
I was, I was doing a bit of, I would add,
I was promoting some show I was doing or
something I'd written and I didn't know
Robin Williams had died and so I tweeted
like something about some show I was
doing and I got like a kind of,
you know,
50 people immediately
tweeted me basically saying,
how dare you promote
something when you know,
we're also upset that Robin Williams has
just died because I had notice of our
music and there's that,
there's that kind of conformance again,
the kind of our Ip conformance
and everybody has to the
RFP and it's all good.
It's all coming from a good place.
It's all coming from places that there's
teaching us how to care and teaching us
how to like level the failed.
Not because how they know that you didn't
know or how they know whether or not
you knew. I didn't know. But
that's really common. I mean,
you can't be expected to be
abreast of every single news story,
especially something like a suicide,
something that comes on and it's not
like something that you have to pay
attention to. Like, you know, a military
operation that we're all aware of. No,
this is a random celebrity
decides to take his life.
How could you possibly be forced
to know about that? And I'm,
the problem is, you know, like on,
on social media we see
ourselves is nonconformist.
But what this does is
create a kind of fearful,
conformist world where you have to say
what everybody else to say and quite
conforming to nonconformity. Yeah. It's
like I would see people that were, um,
you know, um, they dress like rebels,
but they dress like the same rebels.
They're typically unique. You know,
you see someone who's got their hair
is dyed pink and you know, they don't
give a fuck, but you don't give a fuck.
Like everybody around you doesn't give
a fuck. Like you're wearing a uniform,
whether you know it or not. You look
like someone's going to Catholic school.
Like you might think that
you're some sort of a rebel,
but the real rebels are
indistinguishable from everyone else.
And the way they dress and the way they,
they look because they're just
people you know, were there,
there are no real rebels.
Like all real rebel is just someone who
has their own opinion that may or may
not go with the standard opinion
that we're being supposed to,
uh, that we're, we're supposed to absorb.
The idea of conforming to
nonconformity is so ironic though.
It's like the one thing that
you are rallying against.
It's the one thing that you don't
even realize you are becoming.
Yeah. And it's, you know, the, the,
the negative byproducts of all of this,
a a big, it makes people fearful.
It makes people shut the fuck up.
Um, I also what it is, it
declares war on human nature.
You know,
this is the reason why I really wanted
to ride the public shaming book cause I,
I felt like war had been declared on
human nature instead of trying to work out
why people transgress, you know,
and it's sort of compassionate way.
It's, it just, it just destroys
people for transgressing, um,
are and everybody transgresses
Effie human transgressors.
And when we so ferociously destroyer
the people for transgressing,
we're shutting off really
significant realities about humans,
which is a fact that if,
if we tried to understand each other,
it would make the world more compassionate
and we would understand why people
transgressed ball.
Yeah.
What we're talking about too is you're,
you're not talking about rallying
against someone who's committing horrible
atrocities. Someone's committing crimes
against humanity, torturing people,
murdering people. You're, you know, you're
talking about differences of opinion.
Yeah. I mean some people's
transgressions are so serious.
It deserves to overwhelm them and
they deserve to be defined by them.
And we're all like sort of
in, commiserating and we're
all sort of in agreement.
We're all sort of bonding together on
this, like, hey, like as humans we were,
we're not going to tolerate
this behavior because it's evil.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. But this is all
a long way away from the question,
which was about kind of hanging out
with extremist groups and so on.
And when I discovered some things that
I think people would have known at the
time in one was that they were all
conspiracy theorists. You know,
that was what United the Ku Klux Klan
with the Islamic fundamentalist group or
hung out with code [inaudible].
I spent a year with this Islamic group.
Could have had to really spend a year
with them. Yeah. I became like their,
their chauffeur.
They said to me,
oh my Bakary the head of the group
said to me after a few months, like,
I have let you into my life, uh, I've
given you much, I want something in.
So I was like, whoa. And he said,
can you drag me to office world?
I need pencils. Yeah. What do you
need to guess? Photocopying, done,
like crushed the pilot state of Israel.
So I become like a show first up,
driving him everywhere and yeah, that
was the awkward. Did you go home?
Did you,
when you said you wear them for a year,
like Hermione lift like a couple
of miles up the road for me.
You can get up in the morning.
Bye honey.
I'm going to go hang out with
fundamentalism, hang out with Omar.
He needs to pass some
collection boxes for Hamas.
And he said it needs to be
driven to the cash and carry.
Now Dan thought that's a
very scary organization.
This was pre nine 11.
I'm an old.
Most of the stories I've told
them like today for my book them,
which was pre nine 11,
um,
and so less scary.
Like people thought they were ridiculous.
Like not that much had happened to that
stage while I was there with them for
the year though.
I mean all you know now,
so many like suicide bombers and so
on and so many journalists get killed.
Yeah,
that's,
I mean that could have been you easily
if you were dealing with a decade later.
Yes. Or even a couple of,
I mean, when Daniel Pearl,
that was pretty relaxed stages of
the Iraq war, right? Two or three.
I was only what, four years?
And that was the first one, man,
that was the first one.
They had the video.
I remember watching that online against
my own better judgment and hasn't
haunted you. Oh, you can never get past
that one. And what's crazy is the one,
that one,
it had such an impact.
And then I've seen a few of them since
then and they didn't have nearly as much
impact.
It's like slowly but surely you get numb
to it because I've never watched any of
these videos.
But I was in Brooklyn and the taxi driver
told me that he watches like all of
them. And I said, I've never watched
out here with him. And he said, well,
I say the one you really shouldn't
watch Daniel Pearl. Yeah.
I haven't watched anything. So
I did a, what he meant by that.
There was a lot of conspiracy theories
are evolving. That one as well.
There was a lot of conspiracy
theories that there was a,
that he was killed by the CIA in order
to keep people out of there and justify
our attacks on Islamic fundamentalists
and that they had killed him because he
was going to reveal information
about all sorts of different shit.
And there was like a whole
video dedicated to, uh,
describing why these people were not
Arabs and that their accent was wrong.
The,
their size was wrong.
They were built more like a American
military people and the right conspiracy
theories. It's a weird thing. It's because
you mentioned conspiracies. I mean,
you know, I got chased away from
Bilderberg, I snuck into Bohemian Grove.
There are conspiracies.
Um,
and there's also stuff like
operation Northwoods where
the Joint Chiefs of staff,
it's signed that the papers saying
that they were going to try to, uh,
fake attacks on American civilians.
They were going to arm Cuban
friendlies and attack wanton him,
obey the all in order to get us
into a war with Cuba. I mean,
so it's not like it hasn't been proposed
or it hasn't been even act it out.
Like what happened in the Gulf of
Tonkin. I mean, there are real,
real conspiracies that actually do happen
even in its own little way. My, my book,
the minister goats kind
of proves conspiracies.
It proves that that they would charge
in your book, sorry to interrupt you.
What was the difference in your book and
the movie? Uh, okay. In the book, I mean,
I never actually went to Iraq,
the Ewan Mcgregor cat,
so that's kind of based on the goats
were back in the movie in real life.
I just hung around like military
basis in America self, um,
Fort Meade and Fort Bragg,
uh, at the end of the movie,
Ewan McGregor managers to walk through
a wall and I never managed to work.
I said I didn't have the movies
kind of tongue in cheek. Yeah.
The book is more serious.
The book,
the book starts off with
the kind of comedy of all of
this crazy stuff they were
trying out in the seventies and eighties.
Lat,
trying to kill goats just by staring at
them, tried to learn how to be invisible,
which by the way, and after,
after, after a while they adapted.
They went from invisibility to trying
to find a way of not being seen.
So I'm like, that's, you know, I
said like camouflage. No, I invented,
I interviewed this guy who was a military
guy that was work on their remote
viewing. Yeah. Who, who was
it? I would have probably
met this person for his name.
I'll Google was that day.
He went psychically spied
the lot. Best months. Not,
that's not soon determined
that it was a dinosaurs ghost.
A dinosaurs ghost zoning. Really
Sad. Yeah. He's a character.
He was showing me pictures
of his hot girlfriend. Yeah.
He was one of the main that
day it was Joe mcmonagle.
Like all of these real life stories.
Real hot Russian.
Well Dude,
his baton way over side.
So I met and maybe remote
viewed that, uh, you know,
if you're psychic spy, I tell you what,
they're being a black cup military.
Psychic spy isn't as glamorous as it
sounds. Stressful, stressful. Plus,
you've got your black ops, you've got no
light budget, you've got no, you can't.
You can't, you don't, you're
not a lot of coffee machine.
You have to bring your own
coffee and to work. Really. Yeah.
A couple of the remote viewers told me
how annoyed they were that because they
were black up, they had to
bring their own coffee into it.
Plus what does it actually mean to be a
psychic spy working for the U s military?
What it actually means is that like for
20 years you go into some room at Fort
Meade and try and be psychic.
It's kind of a shit job. Yeah.
I interviewed another guy,
I forget his name,
but we actually tried it out and uh,
we tried to remote view things.
Did they have any, did he get any
luck? No. Those me and this guy,
Dj growthy who's a, Oh, yeah, yeah,
yeah. He's a skeptic. Randy Guy. Yeah.
He's a,
a debunker skeptic.
And he and I were on the same page
or like know we, we came up with
some random shapes and we're
supposed to envision this area.
And then we went to the area and he was
trying to find hits. And I'm like, man,
I mean you're talking like angles.
Like you could fuck anywhere you go,
that's man made, you're going to
find angles that are similar to this.
And you know, we picked out a few
colors that were like super common.
You find those colors. Yeah,
we get some really lucky hits,
but think about all the shit that we
were wrong with. And he's all about like,
it's just, don't think too much. Just
let it come to you. Let it come you.
So you're supposed to scribble shit
down. And Yeah. So mind blowingly dumb.
And the uh, ed dames guy
was telling me that, uh,
they had actually had found Osama, I think
it was Osama bin Laden, he was saying,
sorry for,
can't remember correctly,
because it was all
nonsense to me at the time.
But they didn't go after him because
they didn't want to win the war because
they didn't want the war to end.
Right.
Because the people had a vested
interest in keeping the war going.
And that was sort of as a idea behind why
this remote viewing wasn't successful.
But he was citing all these different
instances where we're remote viewing was
successful. And I was like, Ooh
man, I don't know about all that.
Yeah. I remember one time
they were looking for Noriega,
General Noriega and the remote view
with what I called in to find out.
I'm one of the remote viewers.
It might've been at dames,
actually one of the remote viewers
psychically defined that. Um,
Angela Lansbury knew when Noriko
was, oh, that bitch. Yeah.
What? I don't know. What I don't
know is whether they actually for,
you asked Angela Lansbury order.
What I discovered though,
it just been remote viewing.
I wouldn't have wanted to,
to written a metastatic coats because
I found the remote viewing things a bit
boring.
But then what I discovered just through
asking people was there was all this
other shit going on.
Like they were trying to fast for a month,
trying to burst clouds
just by pointing them,
try to kill goats just by
staring at them. And, and,
and that stuff was so fun to me.
And then I discovered after like a year
of, of like interviewing these guys,
I discovered that there was a line,
I'm going to really crooked line but
allied none the less between some of these
crazy and Devis in the night and seventies
and eighties and some of the kind of
exotic in interrogation techniques
that were happening at Guantanamo Bay,
Abu Ghraib. So in the book cause
cause some of the same people,
like there was a colonel could John
Alexander who was involved in like exotic,
um,
you know,
sound blasting and all the nonlethal
weapons and he's a guy should have on your
show actually. Uh, he's incredible
guy. Um, so the monastery goats,
the book sort of starts
funny and gets dark,
whereas the movie kind of stayed funny
and kind of didn't go into the darkness
in that way. How much money they spend
on that remote viewing thing for a long,
$20 million.
Is there any one piece of evidence
that they could point to that was like,
no. Every so often like a unit would get
sick of it. Like it was being run by the,
um, I dunno the, the DEA or
you know,
the,
the u s army or military intelligence
and then it gets sick of it and then
they'd dissolve viewing.
Right. Is that a dames? Okay.
That's not him. No, no. That side of
the Games. It's his website. Yeah.
He's an older gentleman that it
ended up back with the CIA in 1995.
CIA's greatest weapon as the power to
change your life forever, right? Oh,
so now you're using it like, and look,
they have a live support Gal. Look,
she's pretty too, and need live
support calls. Pretty girl.
Why don't they have an angry black
guy who could beat your ass? Nope.
Pretty white girl. It's been
funny. It's like welcoming.
I'm smiling at you might have beautiful
eyes. Do you need live support?
Call me sugar. I'll show you how to find
your dog. Here's something interesting.
You know the guy,
the first guy who ran the remote view
is back in the very earliest days of
remote viewing was a guy called Sydney
Gottlieb and he was the same guy who ran
mk ultra in the 50s like so all
the kind of poisoning people,
this sparking people's drinks with LSD
going off to Cuba to try to assassinate
Castro by putting like a bomb in
his cigar or poisoning his wet suit.
So of this really dark CIA shit that
was happening in the 50s was run by this
Guy Sydney Gottlieb,
and he was the same guy who run the
remote viewers in the 70s I was,
that was kind of interesting. That is
interesting. Yeah. Well, without a doubt.
They've definitely experimented on people
to try to find out whether or not they
could control them. That's a
hundred oh no question. Um,
there's a south of oppression.
Could artichoke. I became
friends with Eric Olsen,
who's father was Franco said,
who's the guy who purportedly was given
LSD by the CIA and then jumped out of a
window in New York and killed himself.
Do you know that Ted Kaczynski was a
part of the Harvard studies on Lsd?
Oh really? Yeah. There,
there was a German documentary called
the net that sort of highlighted this and
it was all about his participation in
the LSD studies and how it pushed him off
the rails. Right. And then he
went fucking crazy and went,
went off to teach at Berkeley,
saved all his money from teaching
and then went to live in the woods.
And Kendall people too
didn't can key CICA is LSD.
I do not know if that's the case. I
mean he might've been. Um, but uh,
the Kaczynski thing is pretty well
documented that he was a part of those
studies. Right. And, uh, you know, I mean,
I have a friend whose sister is out of
her fucking mind. She went on a, uh,
a couple of LSD trips and took
way too much. And to this day,
there was like seven years ago. To
this day, she's all fucked up. Hmm.
So it can happen,
especially if you have,
if you're mentally unstable to begin
with and you get dosed, spiked, you know,
it's totally possible.
I mean,
people that have all of a
slippery grip on reality,
any really traumatic
experience in any real,
anything that's like super perturbing
to your state of consciousness has the
potential to set you off the rails and
a way that you might not be able to
recover from. I mean, it is possible.
And they did a lot of fucking
explode at that LSD with people.
I know it's worse shit than that.
There was this thing called artichoke
where they were like experimenting in I,
I believe this is all been verified.
Their experiment again,
in getting people hooked on heroin and
then withdrawing the heroin and making
them do cold Turkey as a means of getting
information out to them. Wow. Yeah.
And that was like related to Mk ultra.
I mean, yeah. You talked about consent.
Conspiracy has been true. I'm couch
is a conspiracy. That was true.
Yeah. There's plenty of those
that are true and when look,
especially when you're dealing with the
Cold War and this terrible, terrible,
terrible thought that the Soviet Union
was ready to drop bombs and your children
any day of the week and that they're doing
things like this. And then, you know,
the Nazis had been doing things like this
and we know about all the experiments
of the Japanese it did and the rape of
Nam King and the horrible things that the
Nazis had done to the prisoners of war.
I mean,
I'm weren't, some American
didn't m couch S. Dot.
Or in the early days of m couches,
some Americans were,
some American soldiers were
kidnapped by the Korean.
So then there was seen on TV like Sag,
we've announced America and they would
try to work out like how the Koreans and
my memory's really sketchy on us,
but then try to work out like how the
Koreans and managed to brainwash these
three American servicemen so easily.
And that was one of the reasons
why they started mk ultra.
I might be getting confused.
Well,
that's one of the reasons why I wanted
to ask you about your work with extremest
because I always wonder like is
it appealing? Like when you're,
I mean obviously you're not
a white supremacist or an
Islamic fundamentalists or
anything, but when you're with
them for a long period of time,
when you're embedded, is there any draw?
Is there any, uh, somehow or another,
is there any pull towards like
thinking and inclination, a, a,
is there an attraction to either ideology?
I, you know, never to that ideology,
but what I did always like,
um,
like throughout my rights
in Korea at the Times I'm,
I'm at my happiest times are,
I think a story is really working
is when something shifts and May,
like I spent so much time with conspiracy
theorists and then suddenly I'm being
chased by the Bilderberg group
and I go fucking, that's like,
I've become like paranoid. And that's what
I know. Like at the bottom of my brain.
I know that like what's
happening to me is terrifying,
but the fact that I've gone through this
really big change means it's going to
be a really fucking good piece of writing.
And that happened in them and it happened
in the psychopath test to actually
that I became completely drunk with
my psychopaths spotting powers.
Like I went on a course to learn how to
spot psychopaths and I got so drunk with
my psychopaths spotting powers that I
changed and like my friends were saying to
me like, you've really changed Peter
Straughan who wrote the screenplay for the
metastatic goats told me he was concerned
about me because I was so convinced I
could spot psychopaths everywhere.
What do you look for? Um, well, yeah,
nuances of language. Um,
the first half of my book,
the psychopath test sort of teaches people
how to spell [inaudible] and then the
second half becomes like a cautionary
tale to not get so fucking drunk with the
power is that it turns you a little bit
psychopathic black nuances of language.
Um,
you know,
there's like a 20 point checklist where
it all comes from lack of empathy,
lack of remorse. I went, I
started meeting like CEOs and,
and doing the psychopath checklist on
them to see if it's true that you're more
likely to fund psychopathic at the
top of the trees and the bottom. Um,
I'll give you one example. Is that
true? Yeah, I think that is true.
I think you are more likely to find
psychopaths it though at the top of the
trees and at the bottom because
capitalism rewards psychopathic behavior.
Well isn't the definition to that?
A psychopath is someone that has
power or as a sociopath, as someone,
like there's some sort of, uh, you know,
the whole cyber had sociopath thing.
There's a lot of blurry. Yeah. There's
a lot of debate out there is to,
and different psychiatrists
and psychologists will use
the terms. Like, I mean,
the upshot is that added thickness.
Any real difference?
Some people will say there's a
difference, um, because they'll,
they'll bring their own sort of analyses
to the situation. But, but in general,
you're talking about a kind of a lack of
empathy or neurological lack of empathy,
whether it's new or logical or
whether it's through childhood abuse.
That's another big matter of
debate amongst those people. But,
but I'll give you a kind of
classic example from the book.
I went to meet this Haitian
dictator called toto,
constant in jail,
in upstate New York.
I had met him a few times before,
um,
but I met him in jail and
he kept on saying to me,
I want people to like me.
Like I really want people to like
me captain saying that to me.
So finally I said to him, isn't that a
weakness? Like wanting people to like you?
Isn't that a weakness? And he said,
no, no, no, it's not a weakness.
Because if you can get people to like you,
you can manipulate them to do whatever you
want them to do. Whoa. Yeah. So I said,
so are you the sort of person who doesn't
really feel like empathy? And he said,
no. Now empathy is a weakness.
So that that's a well,
that's clearly telltale that I've,
I've, um, I guess he figured, well,
fuck it, I'm in jail. It's
lots of care out of the bag.
I'm not getting out of here.
And all cells sometimes they're like,
like I said this to an old KGB
spy met one time. Like I said,
well you were bullied at school. And
he said, yes, yes, yes, I was a bully.
He said that he was English.
He said I would get out from
behind a tree and had to have it,
like my bag would have bricks ness
and I'd hit somebody over the head,
which is quite, yeah. And I said, he
said, but I'd only get the bullies.
I'd only get the police. So I said, and
how did you feel about that? And he said,
I felt good. And I said, and how do you
feel now? Like all these years later,
looking back on it, how do
you feel now? And he said, I
still feel good. And I said,
so you're not the sort of person
who feels empathy. And he said,
you've really got to the nub of
what kind of crank Kayam he said,
when a dog dies,
like one of my dogs dies.
I feel incredibly upset our cry.
But the human beings that I've hurt
and killed don't feel anything.
Oh yeah.
So if you can get them being honest
about their absence of empathy,
I don't want to hear that.
I mean, I do what I don't
do, but I don't want to know.
They're around, man. Yeah.
Something disturbing about someone
who's just not willing to ever join the
community. You know, they live
amongst you and they're just trying
two,
yeah.
St Montag tray that we see the world
in terms of predators and prey.
And it would be foolish not to
exploit weaknesses at this, you know?
I think there really are psychopaths
out there. There was some people. Yeah.
That's, I think a lot of people
that, the one thing I don't like, uh,
about this sort of psychopath
spot and world is that they,
they're not interested to a large extent.
And what turns somebody that way because
they're just really interested in the
idea that this,
they're just another species out there.
There's just this other species that
aren't quite human and they're look human.
But then it's kind of like
David, I can the Lizard, right?
There's people out there who've adopted
human form, but they're not quite human.
Um, but, uh, but I'm really interested,
this is other psychiatrist I met called
James Gilligan who basically says all
violence is an attempt to
replace shame with self esteem.
So these people were like so battered,
join their childhood,
so humiliated,
so abused that they'd try and regain
some self esteem by committing violence
onto other people.
Hmm. All violence don't like all. I don't
like statements that are so absolutely,
it is a big statement, right?
But as a, as a kind of humanist,
I like that because it's giving some
humanity back to violent people.
It's saying, you know, this is, you
know, it comes from a place of damage.
Whereas the psychopath spotters will
basically say, no, no, they're just,
they're like another species. Yeah.
You know what? I think this, honestly,
I think there's truth in both camps.
Well,
I think there's certainly some people
that are like that and there's some people
that are violence just
because they're angry,
it's stupidity or they're
angry at aggression are there,
they just need some release
in their life and their,
their pent down with all sorts of stress
and I can't handle it and they don't
have an outlet. You know, there's
a lot of people that just,
they're lacking an outlet. And I, I
liken them to overflowing batteries,
like a battery that like I think of
the human body as your human body is
designed to exert a certain amount of
effort to put forth a certain amount of
energy during the day.
And most people don't even remotely
tap into their reserve of energy.
They sit down and their body,
you know,
just conforms to their office chair and
they're there all day and at the end of
the day they sit in their car or they
sit on the bus or the train and they'd
make their way home and which case they
sit on a couch and they sit in front of
the television and their,
their body just has constantly up stress
and it has this desire to exert energy
and it's never met with what it needs.
It never, it never has its
needs fulfilled, fulfilled.
And so then you're in your car and you're
in traffic and someone cuts you off
and be like,
you fucking pay you cash.
You have this unbelievably
angry response because your,
your battery is essentially found there's
an opening, you know, it's like a,
a hole in a water balloon should
water just start squirting out of it.
It can't help it. It's like so bent up
with or pent up with pressure. And if you,
instead of doing that to somebody
in another car, who cotton, hey you,
if you could then go home and he do it
on social media. Everybody haze you,
including that person, and it can
really damage someone's, well.
There's certainly you, you keep
coming back to that. It's a,
it's ending because it's drama series
and books. It's on your mind for awhile.
Hey, do monk, do you mind if I go? No,
that's a perfect way to end it. This
is, this was a great conversation.
I really enjoyed it. I'm so glad that
we did this because as I say, for years,
people have like, oh my God, you gotta go.
Well, I think we could have a hundred
of these. I mean, anytime you're back,
when are you back again? Come
around. La in Naafi citizen. Yeah.
My son's thinking about moving here,
so if it guys, okay, great. If he does,
I'm not going to fucking leave.
I can't be undone at the city to my son.
I hear you. Yeah. Okay. We'll beautiful
man. We'll definitely either way,
one way or another when you're back
in town. Let's do this. Can, I really,
really enjoyed it. I really didn't.
And so your most recent book is,
so you've been publicly shamed it and I'm
sure it's available everywhere. Right?
Like Amazon and all that jazz,
so Barnes and noble,
all that good stuff. And uh, John Ronson
on Twitter, J o. N a is you're a j.
O. H. N that's pretending to be
running a bunch of evil shit.
You're going to get in trouble
for [inaudible] to be me.
I hope he's not shaming you.
We've tried other is isn't
really. Yeah. Oh, ah.
Oh yeah, John. So John Ronson, ladies
and gentlemen. Thank you brother.
I really appreciate Joe's a lot of fun.